[Musique]
super typhon éruption volcanique violent
tremblement de terre et canicule
interminables l'année 2015 a été
ponctuée par des catastrophes naturelles
exceptionnelles
[Musique]
bilan de ces phénomènes terrifiants 20
000 victimes et presque 40 milliards de
dollars de dégâts
2015 s'affiche comme une année record
sur plusieurs points des tempêtes
tropicales d'une puissance inédite des
épisodes de sécheresse particulièrement
longs et des températures les plus
hautes mesurées de puissants
faut-il y voir les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique ou d'autres
phénomènes plus ponctuels comme elles
n'ignore
comment la science peut-elle tenter de
prévoir ses cataclysmes les populations
peuvent-elles se préparer et anticiper
certains de ces événements naturels
[Musique]
de la Cordillère des Andes au plateau
himalayen en passant par les déserts
glacé d'Islande et les îles
paradisiaques du Vanuatu des
scientifiques décryptent ces colères de
la terre et du ciel
rassemblant exclusivement des images
professionnelles saisies au cœur de
l'action ce film présente les
catastrophes naturelles majeures de
l'année 2015 de la plus inoffensive à la
plus dramatique
[Musique]
symbolique et emblématique des
catastrophes naturelles de l'année 2015
le typhon doutwan frappe Taïwan en
septembre
500 mm de pluie soit l'équivalent de
quatre mois de précipitation sont tombés
en seulement 24 heures
l'île de Taïwan est au cœur de la zone
cyclonique du Pacifique et les autorités
sont habituées à lancer des alertes
auprès de la population pour faire
évacuer les zones les plus sensibles et
éviter que les gens ne sortent de chez
eux
pour Fabrice Chauvin spécialiste des
cyclones à Météo France l'île de Taïwan
est dans le Mirador de surveillance de
la communauté scientifique Taïwan qui
est à peu près situé dans cette zone et
dans une zone qui est sujette au cyclone
tropicaux il faut savoir que le l'ouest
du Pacifique Nord c'est la zone la plus
sujette aussi clones tropicaux sur
l'ensemble des cyclones ça doit
représenter peut-être quelque chose
comme 60% des cyclones annuels
l'impact du cyclone a été
particulièrement visible sur les côtes
le littoral a été dévasté par des vagues
exceptionnelles en raison de la
conjonction de deux phénomènes le typhon
et la proximité de la terre et de la
lune provoquant des marées de tempête
c'est une élévation du niveau de la mer
dû à la dépression liée au cyclone donc
la dépression liée au cyclone en fait
elle a tendance comme il y a moins de
pression sur la mer son équilibre il le
trouve un petit peu plus haut par
rapport à ça normal donc une élévation
du niveau de la mer
en urgence les barrages ouvrent leurs
Vannes pour compenser la flux soudain
d’eau de pluie
le rabondance s'explique notamment par
les températures des eaux de surface
anormalement chaudes elles ont stimulé
le nombre et l'intensité des cyclones du
Pacifique Nord 29 au total en 2015 avec
des vents supérieures à 178 km heure
ce film retrace un échantillon de ses
événements climatiques extrêmes
[Musique]
autre île autre menaces ici un désert de
pierre et de glace l'une des zones les
plus hostiles et les plus mystérieuses
de la planète l'Islande
dans ce décor de conte et légendes
nordiques le plus grand glacier d'Europe
donne des signes d'activité étrange
et activités a commencé avec un
déferlement sismique dans toute la
partie nord-ouest du glacier Vatna Yoko
personne ne savait encore ce qui se
passait mais on sentait que quelque
chose de gros se préparait
holgher sigmarson est islandais mais il
travaille en France depuis plus de 20
ans et étudie l'origine du magma grâce à
ses composés radio nucléaires
l'Islande est une zone hautement active
en matière de volcanisme l'île est
située juste au-dessus d'un point chaud
c'est à dire une remontée de magma
depuis les profondeurs de la terre
jusqu'à la surface de la croûte
terrestre
l'Islande est aussi localisée à la
limite de deux plaques terrestres en
train de s'écarter l'une de l'autre en
autorisant des remontées de magma depuis
le manteau et créant une dorsale
océanique avec une telle situation les
moindres signes précurseurs d'une
éruption attire rapidement l'attention
de la communauté scientifique
or sous ce glacier géant est installé un
volcan peu connu et pourtant l'un des
plus gros d'Islande le barbare Bonga
était un volcan très connu pour les
Islandais ailleurs il n'est pas très
connu parce qu'il n'a pas été très actif
depuis plusieurs décennies voire même
des siècles
la dernière petite éruption s'est
produite en 1903 mais auparavant la
dernière grosse éruption avait eu lieu
au 15ème siècle en 1480
la spécificité du volcan barder Bonga
c'est que son cratère principal est
complètement caché sous la neige
impossible donc de voir directement
jaillir quoi que ce soit du volcan
mais les scientifiques Islandais ont
réussi à cartographier le sous-sol pour
découvrir la physionomie cachée du
barder bunga un vaste et profond cratère
effondré ou caldera dans les bords
culminent 400 mètres au-dessus du fond
du cratère
et par dessus 800 mètres de glace un
potentiel dévastateur immense
une éruption se produisait dans le
cratère du barbe à bouga lui-même cela
ferait fondre la glace et avec 800
mètres d'épaisseur cela générerait un
flot catastrophique qui jaillirait vers
le nord et vers le sud
ce qui est potentiellement plus
dangereux c'est la présence d'usine
hydroélectrique sur les rivières qui
proviennent du glacier et tous ces
villages au sud et ce jusqu'à la mer
heureusement le barbare Bounga est
implanté dans une zone désertique et les
routes d'accès ont été coupées très tôt
sauf pour les scientifiques
les habitants les plus proches sont
habitués aux colères de la terre en
Islande et préparé à vivre en autonomie
en cas de coup dur
éventuelle éruption on pourrait vivre en
autonomie ici pendant un bon moment
on vit dans un pays en formation et on
est habitué à ces manifestations
géologiques
ce genre de choses peuvent arriver dans
10 ans ou demain c'est comme ça
sur ce terrain relativement plat ce sont
bien les inondations potentielles qui
poseraient le plus de problèmes l'eau
pourrait se propager largement à très
grande vitesse et causer beaucoup de
dégâts aux infrastructures
nous sommes sur la route 1
en Islande elle connecte le côté nord du
pays
au côté sud
si on perd ce pont il faut faire un
détour de 1400 km à la place de 30 km
alors on va faire tout ce qu'on peut
pour sauver ce pont
il faut qu'on attende et qu'on voit
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas d'inondation
mais on ne sait jamais
heureusement après quelques jours
d'attente l'éruption sous le glacier
tant redoutée ne se produit pas le magma
semble évacuer latéralement et se ferait
un chemin jusqu'à la surface en dehors
du glacier
la croûte terrestre se fissure puis
s'ouvre au nord de l'immense calotte
blanche
le magma peut alors jaillir à l'air
libre d'une manière spectaculaire
l'activité de 3 cratères s'est concentré
dans une seule partie pour former un
seul grand cratère d'environ un demi km
de long avec trois fontaines très
actives et un grand lac de lave ou de
magma dans le cratère qui se déversait
ensuite comme une rivière et formée à
l'extérieur un vaste champ de lave
à ce stade de l'éruption les
scientifiques ne sont que modérément
rassurés les risques de débats que le
glaciaire est d'inondation géante semble
s'éloigner cependant personne ne peut
prédire la suite des événements
la lave continue à se déverser depuis la
fissure volcanique à la vitesse de 300
mètres cubes par seconde un vaste flux
qui s'étale dans la plaine en direction
du nord du sud et de l'ouest
un phénomène nouveau apparaît peu à peu
sous l'oeil des scientifiques le glacier
semble s'enfoncer au-dessus du volcan
aucune fonte n'est observée par ailleurs
ce phénomène pourrait être la clé qui
explique que le pire scénario d'éruption
était évité sans
modement des blocs au-dessus de la
chambre magmatique a poussé le magma
depuis la chambre d'une manière latérale
d'autres disent que le jaillissement du
magma par la fissure a diminué la
pression dans la chambre magmatique
au-dessous du volcan central et a
provoquer son effondrement mais c'est un
peu le problème de la poule et de l'oeuf
en février l'éruption finit par
s'arrêter la pression dans le volcan
semble s'être évacuée et le magma n'est
plus poussé à la surface de la Terre au
total le barbare bouga a craché 85 km²
de lave c'est-à-dire de quoi recouvrir
entièrement la ville de Paris sous 5
mètres de lave une grosse éruption
proportionnellement bien inférieure à
celle d'un passé plus lointain
c'est assez gros mais dans le passé le
même volcan craché 25 km³ il y a 8400
ans donc plus proche de la période de la
déglaciation
plus on avance dans le temps plus on a
l'impression qu'un volume de plus en
plus petit de magma est produit lors des
éruptions
un lien mystérieux uniré donc des
glaciations et activités volcaniques et
sismiques Robert new wood spécialiste
des sciences de la Terre s'est pencher
sur cette corrélation
il y avait une calotte glaciaire géante
sur toute l'Europe du Nord ce qui
faisait 3 km d'épaisseur
ces grosses masses sont apparues et ont
provoqué l'enfoncement de la croûte
terrestre
quand la couche de glace a disparu la
situation s'est inversée la zone qui
supportait le plus de poids est remontée
et les zones autour sont descendues et
ce processus durent depuis des milliers
d'années la Terre est encore en train de
s'en remettre aujourd'hui
les cicatrices de ces déformations sont
parfois encore visibles la terre est
remontée de plusieurs dizaines de mètres
aux alentours des anciennes calottes
heureusement ce phénomène de rebond post
glaciaire n'a plus les effets
dévastateurs d'autrefois
la grosse période de déglassation s'est
produite il y a 15000 ans donc si vous
m'aviez posé la question il y a 15000
ans je pense que nous soyons en train
d'assister à de grosses séismes de
grosses éruptions volcaniques et nous
pourrions dire que c'est à cause de la
fonte de la calotte glaciaire que nous
assistons à toutes ces catastrophes mais
aujourd'hui les 10 grandes calottes
glaciaires qui existaient il y a 20 000
ans sur notre planète ont disparu il ne
reste plus qu'une seule au Groenland
même si celle-ci se mettait à fondre
très rapidement et si nous commençons à
avoir beaucoup de séismes dans le
voisinage du Groenland cela n'aurait pas
un très grand impact
les éruptions du barbare Bonga seraient
en tout cas moins prolifique en magma
que par le passé impossible cependant
d'en tirer plus de conclusion pour le
futur
le lien c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
magma qui s'est créé à la fin de la
glaciation et il y a de moins en moins
de magma générés parce que la croûte
terrestre est encore en train de se
remettre après les énormes glaciers
qu'il y avait il y a 10 000 ans personne
ne pourrait vous dire que les éruptions
seront plus petites dans le futur parce
que personne ne le sait ce ne sont que
des hypothèses
malgré ses fontaines de la très
spectaculaires l'éruption du barbare
bunga a donc été un événement naturel
sans dommage ni victime
pour poursuivre dans cette série de
catastrophes bénignes une autre éruption
qui aurait pu cependant présenter bien
des risques en raison de son voisinage
on regagne quelques degrés en prenant la
direction du sud de l'archipel japonais
ou le volcan Sakura donne des signes de
réveil
explosion panache de fumée et de cendres
ce volcan installé sur une péninsule
habitée par 4000 personnes fait partie
des plus actifs du Japon avec 500 à 1000
petites éruptions chaque année
[Musique]
le problème c'est que la centrale
nucléaire de Sendai installée à 50 km
vient d'être redémarré quatre ans après
la tragédie de Fukushima qui avait
occasionné l'arrêt de toutes les unités
de production du Japon
le niveau d’alerte éruption a donc été
relevé à 4 pour que les habitants soient
prêts à évacuer
[Musique]
après plusieurs semaines de tension le
volcan japonais semble finalement
redevenir plus paisible son cratère
principal s'obstruant progressivement
avec un bouchon de lave
[Musique]
là non plus ni victime ni dégâts à
déplorer du moins pour le moment nul
doute que les vulcanologues japonais
vont garder à l'oeil ce volcan
Sakurajima et sa centrale nucléaire dans
les prochaines années
[Musique]
une catastrophe survenue en avril au
Chili donne la mesure de ce qui les
attend
6 heures du soir la journée se termine
dans la zone touristique des Grands Lacs
à 50 km de la ville de Puerto mant
[Musique]
dans cette région paisible et animée des
bruits souterrains se font soudain
entendre
un mystérieux grondement parcourt les
contreforts de la cordillère des Andes
pas d'autres préavis pas d'autres signal
d'alerte 15 minutes seulement après les
premiers grondements annonciateurs un
volcan en sommeil depuis 40 ans le
Calbuco éruque un panache de fumée très
dense
et il y a très peu
il y a une station chilienne
d'observation à proximité et il ne
remarquait qu'une heure avant l'éruption
un signal qui pouvait être interprété
comme une remontée de magma
toute la Cordillère des Andes est très
active en termes de volcanisme c'est une
zone de subduction ou une plaque
océanique de la croûte terrestre
s'enfonce sous la plaque de l'Amérique
du Sud
quand la plaque océanique s'enfonce dans
la zone de subduction elle se transforme
et toute l'eau est pressée vers les
profondeurs ce qui diminue le point de
fonte et provoque la remontée de magma
cette colonne de fumée provient des gaz
sous pression piégés dans le magma à
l'intérieur du réservoir du volcan
poussé vers la sortie avec violence il
se dépressurise et prennent du volume en
entraînant de très petites particules de
lave
[Musique]
cette colonne est exceptionnellement
haute elle atteint la limite entre la
troposphère et la stratosphère à 20 km
d'altitude
le plus grand risque c'est que la
colonne de cendre finisse par
s'effondrer sur la ville de Puerto monde
et ses 220 000 habitants
et qui se dilue au contact de
l'atmosphère
sa forme un genre de champignon au
sommet
et quand elle ne parvient plus à se
tenir elle s'effondre en nuée ardente
qui dévale les vallées et les plaines en
transportant des matières très chaudes
qui peuvent être très dévastatrices
heureusement le vent venu du Pacifique
se lève et éloigne le panache en
direction de l'est des montagnes
inhabitées
il se propage jusqu'en Argentine qui est
obligé de fermer son espace aérien les
cendres sont une menace pour les
réacteurs des avions
doucement le prince de très petites
particules de moins de 10 micromètres
sont très mauvaises à respirer les bords
sont aiguisés et peuvent déchirer les
poumons et le système digestif
[Musique]
Puerto monte et temporairement sauvé par
sécurité une zone de 20 km autour duquel
Boucau et tout de même évacué
après une période d'accalmie à la tombée
de la nuit nouvelle explosion
[Musique]
l'éruption entre dans une nouvelle phase
des décharges électrostatiques en
d'autres termes des éclairs se
déchaînent au-dessus du cratère du
kalbot
après il y a eu les éclairs de feu
un nuage impressionnant le voyant en
pleine nuit c'était très proche on avait
mal un nuage de sable est arrivé très
épais
on sait que c'était de la grêle qui est
tombée
l'éruption dure trois jours et trois
nuits sans faire aucune victime humaine
en revanche la désolation est totale
dans le paysage
le volcan a vomi 210 millions de mètres
cubes de cendres sur les forêts les
rivières les plaines et les habitations
environnantes
[Musique]
pour voir à quoi ça ressemblait et j'ai
trouvé le restaurant dans cet état il
est complètement au sol
100% du restaurant est perdu
je suis né et j'ai grandi ici et je
voudrais continuer à travailler dans ces
lieux
ce sont des accidents de la nature ça
peut se produire ici ou ailleurs
c'est le destin
et c'est nos caillou natation notre
garage s'est effondré et le toit d'une
maison un peu ancienne s'est fracturé et
tordu
on a essayé en vain de se procurer du
carburant et de la nourriture pour les
chiens parce qu'on n'avait rien emporté
avec nous
et nous n'avons pu rentrer chez nous que
le lendemain pour voir les dommages que
la maison avait subi
ce ne sont pas les projections de lave
qui ont posé le plus de problèmes car
elles sont tombées dans un petit
périmètre de 5 km autour du volcan le
frais péril ce sont les tonnes de
cendres accumulées sur les toits des
maisons qui menacent de rompre à tout
instant
6000 personnes ont été évacuées pour
éviter qu'elle ne soit prise au piège et
c'est cet homme mathématique
c'est ça qu'on est en train de dégager
en ce moment
est aussi touristique et ça va poser des
problèmes économiques
en ce qui concerne les exploitations on
estime que les sangs ont créé des
problèmes assez importants avec les
élevages
[Musique]
volcaniques peuvent être très riches en
fluorine une substance qui colle aux
particules de cendres
si les animaux en ingèrent beaucoup cela
va attaquer et dissoudre leurs dents et
leurs eaux
mais le principal reste la chute des
toitures des maisons sous le poids des
cendres et la pollution de l'eau des
sources
plus une goutte d'eau potable dans les
environs la cendre et le soufre ont
contaminé toutes les rivières la couche
de débris volcanique est parfois si
épaisse qu'on ne peut plus discerner
l'eau
[Musique]
donc c'est mon ami
de 4 jours jusqu'à mercredi après quoi
la pluie est annoncée
il faut qu'on se dépêche de nettoyer et
de sécuriser les maisons défoncées
la pluie n'est pas à prendre à la légère
dans cette zone du Chili les nuages
chargés de condensation au-dessus du
Pacifique Sud sont bloqués par les Andes
et peuvent dégénérer en violents orages
en coulé debout et de cendres mélangés
après plusieurs mois de recul les
vulcanologues réussissent cependant à
modérer l'ampleur de l'éruption du
Calbuco
dans quelques années on s'en rappellera
comme une petite éruption elle a été
importante pour ceux qui vivent à
proximité du volcan bien sûr mais le
volume du magma estimé était autour de
0,1 km3 ou à peine plus
les ruption du volcan chilien n'a pas
fait de victimes humaine mais provoqué
600 millions de dollars de dégâts
ce qui a été évité au Chili s'est
produit en Indonésie
après 400 ans de sommeil le volcan
synaboum s'est réveillé il y a 5 ans
depuis il traverse des épisodes éruptifs
réguliers et impressionnants
[Musique]
le dernier en date a commencé au mois de
juin sa forme caractéristique une lave
très visqueuse qui s'écoule peu mais
génère d'impressionnantes couler
pyroclastique
il s'agit de ses épées nuages de cendres
et de particules de lave qui s'élèvent
puis s'effondre sous leur propre poids
en dévalant les pentes du volcan
11000 personnes sont évacuées et
déplacés une vraie catastrophe pour les
paysans qui n'ont plus accès à leur
culture et leurs ressources depuis
plusieurs mois
une personne a trouvé la mort en se
rendant dans le périmètre interdit alors
que le volcan semblait calme
les coulées pyroclastiques sont
imprévisibles et peuvent s'étendre sur 4
km autour du cratère causant cette fois
145 millions de dollars de dommages
agricoles
on quitte temporairement les colères de
la terre pour s'intéresser aux colères
du ciel qui ont été parmi les plus
ravageuses cette année en termes de
victimes et de dégâts
ce n'est pas forcément l'événement le
plus impressionnant mais c'est un de
ceux qui ont coûté le plus cher en 2015
les énormes chutes de neige au nord-est
des États-Unis et du Canada ont provoqué
au total 3 milliards de dollars de
pertes
une seule victime est à déplorer dans un
malheureux accident de luge
trafic paralysé activités économiques
congelées toi abîmé et jambe cassées en
glissant sur des plaques de verglas les
assurances ont déboursés plus de 2
milliards et demi de dollars pour
couvrir les dommages occasionnés par les
tempêtes de neige prolongées pendant
plusieurs semaines
[Musique]
à New York ou dans la région de Boston
plus de 3 mètres de neige sont tombés au
total
plongeant les villes et leurs habitants
dans une chape blanche et opaque
moins poétique et plus effrayant
cette année 2015 la saison des cyclones
a été particulièrement effrénée dans le
Pacifique
la raison principale le retour d'El Niño
un phénomène climatique qui se produit
en moyenne tous les trois à sept ans
un des principaux sujets d'études pour
les prévisionnistes sur le long terme
comme Jacques Richon qui travaille sur
la météo du trimestre suivant pour Météo
France
il s'agit d'une anomalie de la
température de surface de l'océan dans
le Pacifique
habituellement c'est ce qu'on voit sur
ce schéma les vents dominants sur le
Pacifique sont des alizés qui poussent
les os de surface les plus chaudes vers
l'ouest et puis la situation El Niño où
on voit que les zones en rouge ce sont
décalées vers le centre et l'est du
Pacifique donc les températures les plus
chaudes autour de 26 à 32°c se
retrouvent maintenant beaucoup plus à
l'est la contrepartie côté atmosphère
c'est que au dessus de ces eaux les plus
chaudes il y a aussi les orages les plus
violents la convection donc les
mouvements verticaux les plus forts et
les précipitations les plus forts
tous les lignes se valent pas et cette
année un phénomène particulièrement fort
est annoncé on est parti pour avoir un
Lignon fort
parmi les plus forts des 50 dernières
années
on sait pas encore si ça va être le
record le plus fort mais en tout cas on
a un igno qui est vraiment fort cette
année on va dire classique va pas
dépasser 1,5 degrés le celui de 90
198798 est arrivé à 2,3 2,5 degrés
suivant la région qu'on prend
aujourd'hui on en est à 2 degrés sachant
qu'on n'a pas encore atteint le maximum
résultat une saison cyclonique
exceptionnelle au-dessus du Pacifique
ouragan cyclone ou typhon quel que soit
les noms qu'on leur donne en fonction de
la zone où elle se produisent ces
tempêtes tourbillonnantes ont battu
plusieurs records dans les tempêtes
tropicales dès que le vend dépasse ce
seuil de 120 km/h on les passe en
catégorie cyclone en deçà entre 120 et
60 km/h c'est une tempête tropicale et
encore en dessous c'est une dépression
tropicale donc en général on prend en
charge en prévision le phénomène dès
qu'il atteint le stade de dépression
tropicale on commence à être vigilant
sur le phénomène et quand il atteint le
seuil de tempête tropicale donc c'est à
dire 60 km/h on lui donne un nom
qui permettra ensuite de le de le suivre
de manière plus simple
elle n'ignore se manifeste donc par un
réchauffement hors du commun des eaux de
surface à l'est du Pacifique un
ingrédient décisif dans la formation
d'un des événements les plus
retentissants de cette année 2015
l'ouragan Patricia
la zone n'est pas coutumière des
ouragans mais en ce début d'automne les
effets des lignaux commencent à être
forts les os sont plus chaudes de 2
degrés par rapport au normal
saisonnières d'après Eric gilliardi
climatologue c'est une zone où il va y
avoir quelques cyclones mais beaucoup
moins intense et surtout ils vont ils
vont pas se développer de la même
ampleur que celui Patricia patricia est
directement lié au fait qu'on a une igno
en ce moment le fait que les eaux soient
chaudes à l'est et reste chaudes c'est
la source d'énergie de l'ouragan donc il
a pu se développer alors des sources des
graines d'ouragan il y en a tout le
temps en permanence maintenant le fait
qu'il se développe en véritable ouragan
de l'ampleur de Patricia ou d'autres
sont liés au fait que les conditions
océaniques atmosphériques sont propices
au développement
dans ces conditions particulières se
forment un phénomène remarquable
l'ouragan Patricia s'intensifie à une
vitesse exceptionnelle
il passe en seulement 24 heures de
tempête tropicales à cyclones de
catégorie 5 théoriquement ils peuvent se
développer jusqu'à une amplitude
maximale qui est celle qui a atteint
Patricia en général pour la plupart des
ouragans il y a des phénomènes qui vont
venir limiter cette amplification des
eaux qui vont refroidir l'arrivée d'un
continent une circulation atmosphérique
qui va déstabiliser l'ouragan en
altitude donc on regarde les conditions
spécifiques de ces ouragan il est il
s'est vraiment développé il y avait rien
qui l'empêchait d'atteindre son
intensité théorique extrême
c'est un ouragan gavé d'énergie qui
fonce sur l'Amérique centrale Patricia
enregistre un nouveau record celui des
vitesses de vent dans le nord du
Pacifique avec 265 km heure
la violence de Patricia fait des
victimes 12 personnes trouvent la mort
dans des glissements de terrain
provoqués par les pluies diluviennes ou
à cause des arbres des racines et
heureusement le trajet de l'ouragan
évite les plus grosses centres urbains
sur la côte mexicaine les autorités ont
prévu des mesures de secours pour
accueillir près de 260 000 personnes au
final seul 50 000 sont évacués
l'ouragan Patricia s'enfonce à
l'intérieur des terres en direction d'un
massif montagneux en perdant rapidement
de sa puissance
le coût total des dégâts qu'il a
engendré et estimé à 5 milliards de
dollars soit 20 fois plus que les dégâts
imputés à un autre cyclone qui s'est
produit en Asie du Sud-Est en effet
l'évaluation économique des catastrophes
et sujette à de fortes variations en
fonction du pays où elle se produisent
le problème avec cette évaluation c'est
que les catastrophes les plus coûteuses
se produisent dans les pays les plus
riches
cela fausse donc l'évaluation des
dommages en fonction des pays les plus
développés
à l'échelle du monde le même ouragan
coûtera plus cher aux États-Unis qu'en
Chine par exemple
simplement parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de richesses sur le passage de la
tempête
illustration avec un typhon dévastateur
aux Philippines qui étaient le plus
meurtrier de l'année
les vents ont atteint une intensité très
forte de 210 km heure
les vastes pleines risicoles ont été
submergées par les inondations dues à la
pluie et au vagues gigantesque
47 personnes ont perdu la vie aux
Philippines ces quatre fois plus qu'au
Mexique à cause de l'ouragan Patricia
cependant les dommages économiques
causés dans ce pays en développement ont
été 20 fois moins élevés qu'en Amérique
du Nord soit 231 millions de dollars
pour essayer de comprendre les raisons
de l'intensité de ce typhon il faut se
tourner à nouveau vers ninio mais le
phénomène concerne normalement les eaux
du Pacifique Est et pas de l'Ouest
[Musique]
les eaux chaudes se déplacent dans l'Est
mais elle reste chaude à l'ouest
c'est à dire qu'elles vont rester à des
températures suffisamment élevées pour
que des ouragans puissent se développer
donc c'est plutôt une extension de la
zone des ouragans auxquels on assiste
pendant un igno qu'un déplacement de la
zone parce que la zone dans laquelle ces
ouragants peuvent naître c'est temps
est un phénomène qui monte en puissance
et en chaleur tout au long de l'année
2015 il ne peut donc être rendu
responsable de toutes les catastrophes
naturelles atmosphériques de cette année
l'un des cyclones les plus marquants pas
aux Vanuatu c'est par exemple produit
avant que l'enfant terrible du climat
commence à manifester ses premiers
effets
[Musique]
une petite centaine d'îles tropicales
entourée de barrières de corail et
couvertes de végétation luxuriante
l'archipel du Vanuatu revient
régulièrement dans le classement des
pays où les gens sont le plus heureux
[Musique]
pourtant en mars 2015 le Vanuatu a été
frappé par une catastrophe naturelle
dont l'ampleur n'avait pas été égalé de
mémoire humaine
le 6 mars une anomalie barométrique est
détectée un peu plus au nord à la
latitude des îles Fidji une simple chute
de pression pour le moment mais les
services météo sont en alerte avant
l'avènement des de l'air satellitaire on
pouvait rater des cyclones si c'était
des cyclones qui se qui naissaient en
plein milieu de l'océan et qui avait
aucun bateau qui qui pouvait observer ce
phénomène on pouvait rater des cyclones
bon aujourd'hui c'est quasiment
impossible de rater un cyclone ensuite
parlent l'injection des données
d'observation dans les modèles on peut
prévoir sa trajectoire son son cycle de
vie son intensité et en général on est
plutôt assez bon
en trois jours la pression atmosphérique
continue de baisser
l'eau de l'océan Pacifique est chaude
plus de 26 degrés sur au moins 50 mètres
de profondeur une anomalie de
température en surface qui ne peut pas
être imputée à El ninio puisse au mois
de mars les effets du phénomène ne sont
pas encore perceptibles
on va pas parler des millions on va
parler d'un pack du réchauffement
climatique un air plus chaud contient
plus d'humidité donc quand il pleut il
pleut plus et quand il pleut beaucoup
plus comme pendant un ouragan il pleut
vraiment encore beaucoup plus donc si
vous avez 26 degrés mais que en même
temps vous avez une le sommet de
l'atmosphère qui est également chaud
vous aurez pas de développement
cyclonique il faut qu'il se soit chaud
en bas et froid en haut ça c'est la
condition pour rendre l'atmosphère
instable et propice au développement des
cyclones
ce qui aurait pu naître qu'un incident
du baromètre dégénère en dépression
tropicale un plafond de plus en plus
nuageux de la pluie et du vent la
dépression s'organise et requalifiée en
cyclone baptisé PAM
il poursuit son chemin vers le sud
fonçant en droit sur l'archipel des
Vanua
des vents jusqu'à 250 km/h déferle sur
les îles
tous les arbres sont secoués arrachés
par la violence du phénomène
[Musique]
l'essentiel des maisons est construit en
matériaux naturels feuilles de palmier
madrier de bois ils sont balayés comme
des fétus de paille meubles
ustensiles et outils sont emportés dans
la course du cyclone
ce qui s'est passé là c'est un ouragan
extrêmement fort des ouragans cette
intensité on en connaît pas beaucoup
puisqu'ils arrivent par définition peu
PAM est un cyclone majeur comme il y a
d'autres cyclones majeures chaque année
encore une fois la particularité de
femmes c'est d'avoir touché des zones
habitées
au maximum de son intensité
et qui plus est ce sont des zones
habités avec peu de relief et donc très
vulnérable au marais de tempête et au
phénomène de pluie et des inondations
pendant 36 heures PAM reste bloqué à
l'intensité maximum de la catégorie 5
puis après une nuit et une journée
d'angoisse totale pour les habitants PAM
poursuit sa route et s'éloigne plus au
sud dans l'océan Pacifique en perdant
peu à peu de son intensité un phénomène
marin c'est-à-dire à partir du moment où
ça touche terre et son espérance de vie
et de quelques heures voire quelques oui
24 heures quoi mais il y a hyper toute
son énergie en général il s'écroule il
s'écroule assez rapidement c'est
compliqué parce que les vanuatus ce sont
des petites îles souvent quand ils
passent sur des petites îles ils vont
des fois il s'affaiblissent un petit peu
et hop il repasse sur l'océan et il se
régénère en humidité et ils peuvent
redevenir des cyclones très forts
80% des bâtiments sont détruits seuls
les constructions en dur ont été
relativement épargnés tout le reste est
au sol
[Musique]
on écoutait le vent qui souffle fort et
tout d'un coup on a vu le toit de cette
maison qui commençait à s'envoler
le vent avait tordu les tôles du toit et
les a déposés sur la route là-bas
et puis on a vu les murs de cette maison
s'effondrer d'un seul coup
les secours s'organisent dans les
premières heures avec les moyens du bord
et des habitants volontaires comme Peter
qui travaille dans un centre social
on était quatre ou cinq le troisième
jour et maintenant nous sommes une
centaine de bénévoles une trentaine
d'engins et 6 bateaux qui faisaient le
tour des îles aux alentours à la
rencontre des communautés isolées pour
leur apporter des médicaments de l'aide
et éventuellement des soins
il y avait des équipes avec des
tronçonneuses d'autres équipes avec des
générateurs sur des camions pour
recharger les batteries des habitants et
bien sûr des équipes médicales qui ont
fait le tour des îles
on a apporté près de 250 ml d'eau et 5
tonnes de nourriture on a fait des kits
avec des marteaux et des clous qu'on a
laissé aux communautés pour aider les
gens à récupérer leur matériau de
construction et rebâtir comme il pouvait
les hélicoptères prennent ensuite le
relais
vue du ciel on comprend facilement les
dégâts infligés les maisons n'ont plus
de toi les arbres tropicaux qui gardent
habituellement leurs feuilles toute
l'année sont complètement dépouillées
tout a été arraché par le cyclone
les gens agités des drapeaux blancs pour
essayer d'attirer mon attention pour que
je me pose plusieurs groupes avaient mis
le feu dans des champs pour dessiner un
H comme help ou hélicoptère
quand les autorités parviennent à
rétablir le contact avec toutes les îles
un premier bilan peut être effectué 16
morts et 132 000 personnes touchées par
ce violent cyclone les infirmiers de
l'hôpital de Tana sont encore sous le
choc même s'ils étaient préparés depuis
plusieurs jours à l'arrivée de la
tempête
il y a un système d'alerte qui a bien
marché et rapidement
on a reçu des messages d'alerte sur nos
téléphones et la plupart d'entre nous
c'était préparé
tout cela on ne s'attendait pas un
cyclone d'une telle magnitude
[Musique]
vous voyez le métal de ces fenêtres
il est très solide c'est de l'acier
galvanisé mais avec toutes les
vibrations du auvent les fenêtres et les
persiennes ont été arrachées
ce qui est exceptionnel au Vanuatu c'est
la rapidité avec laquelle les secours
s'organisent débrouillard et solidaires
les habitants commencent à reconstruire
sans attendre l'aide internationale qui
dit maison légère dit maison fragiles
mais aussi maison rapide à rebâtir dès
les premiers jours les constructions se
redressent sur les îles
j'ai préparé à manger et demander à mes
cousins de venir m'aider à fabriquer des
parpaings pour pouvoir reconstruire nos
maisons
mais la reconstruction très rapide ne
doit pas cacher les conséquences
sérieuses sur le long terme 500 millions
de dollars de dégâts et des problèmes
sanitaires qui ne vont pas tarder à
émerger le capitaine Benjamin
responsable des premiers secours est
préoccupés
aujourd'hui on va sur une île juste à
côté de l'île principale fate dans un
village avec environ 160 personnes qui
n'ont pas vu un médecin depuis la
catastrophe
on va surtout des blessures infectées
des infections gastro-intestinales on
essaye de les traiter et de les soigner
dans les villages pour leur éviter de se
rendre à l'hôpital
les hôpitaux locaux sont déjà
complètement débordés on essaie donc de
soigner un maximum de personnes à
domicile pour éviter d'engorger les
hôpitaux et leur permettre de continuer
à tourner efficacement
les vanuatus ont intérêt à reconstruire
rapidement ils ne sont pas au coeur de
la zone la plus cyclonique du Pacifique
mais de tels pourraient être à redouter
selon les chercheurs en raison du
réchauffement climatique
dans le futur les eaux de surface vont
être plus chaude et l'intensité des
tempêtes est directement liée à la
température des eaux qu'elle traverse
dans les prévisions sur les
comportements des ouragans étaient
typhons dans le futur il y a beaucoup
d'études qui ne sont pas toutes d'accord
d'ailleurs mais elles suggèrent toutes
que les tempêtes pourraient être moins
nombreuses mais plus intenses
et si le réchauffement climatique se
combinait avec un Lignon très fort les
effets de l'un et de l'autre serait-il
démultipliés
c'est un scénario sur lequel la science
n'a pas encore suffisamment de recul
mais qui fait l'objet de nombreuses
recherches
amplifie
de la planète amplifie les phénomènes
extrêmes qui existent de façon naturelle
là c'est la conjonction de du
réchauffement climatique ou chaque année
ça se réchauffe un peu plus et des
lignes on a vu qu'elle ninio c'est un
quart affecte un quart de la surface de
la planète donc quand il y a un degré de
réchauffement des minions il y a 0,1
degrés en plus au niveau global pour
achever ce tour d'horizon des
dérèglements climatiques il faut ajouter
au phénomène très médiatisés comme El
ninio ou le réchauffement planétaire
d'autres explications météorologiques
plus mystérieuses moins connue mais dont
l'impact a été cette année significatif
c'est l'une des catastrophes naturelles
les plus longues et les plus coûteuses
en 2015
direction la côte sud-ouest des
États-Unis en Californie ou un épisode
de sécheresse dur depuis plusieurs
années
et cet été il semble en passe de
dégénérer
la végétation est extrêmement sèche
les réserves d'eau sont au plus bas le
soleil brille implacablement
des ingrédients hautement inflammables
pour embrasser les grandes forêts de
conifères et de feuillus
chaque année les États du sud-ouest des
États-Unis sont victimes de ces
incendies mais en 2015 ils prennent des
proportions inégales
[Musique]
les feux se déclenchent simultanément
aux quatre coins de la Californie mais
aussi dans l'État de Washington dans
l'Oregon dans l'Utah et dans le Montana
plus qu'à 30 foyers se conçu au même
moment en plein cœur de l'été mobilisant
11000 pompiers à travers le pays
la sécheresse a été provoquée depuis les
vers dernier par un système météo figé
qui empêchait les tempêtes d'arriver en
Californie
les pluies ont lieu presque entièrement
en hiver en Californie et ces dernières
années les modèles météo empêchaient les
tempêtes d'arriver
c'est un phénomène météorologique peu
connu qui est responsable notamment de
la sécheresse sur les côtes
californiennes l'oscillation décennale
du Pacifique
il s'agit d'un refroidissement anormal
des eaux de surface du Pacifique qui
repousse les eaux chaudes vers le Nord
et le Sud
qui revient de manière épisodique tous
les deux à 7 ans là on est sur des
phénomènes qui aussi à l'échelle de la
dizaine d'années
et qui apporte une anomalie de
température positive le long des côtes
de l'Amérique du Nord sur ce schéma on
voit les anomalies de température dans
le nord du Pacifique on a toute une zone
d'anomalies dont des anomalies très très
fortes le long des côtes de la
Californie américain du Nord et ça c'est
un phénomène qui est aussi sur des
échelles beaucoup plus longues donc à
l'échelle de plusieurs dizaines d'années
et qui a commencé début 2014
6 fois tribuer la sécheresse un
phénomène climatique de grande échelle
c'est plutôt à ce phénomène là qui vient
se conjuguer maintenant avec le ninio
qui se développe
l'oscillation décennales du Pacifique se
déroule sur un cycle de 20 à 30 ans
environ et ses interactions avec El
ninio sont encore très mal connues
les scientifiques peuvent seulement
constater que les effets de ces
mécanismes climatiques à grande échelle
se combinent parfois comme cette année
en fait c'est une bonne illustration à
tous les endroits de la planète il y a
ces variations à différents fréquences
jour nuit on va voir le la météo
quelques jours on va avoir les saisons
et on a aussi maintenant d'une année sur
l'autre elle Niño une définition l'autre
donc en fait à chaque fois de la terre
les variations
sont liées à tous ces effets qu'on
comprend maintenant de mieux en mieux on
a le réchauffement climatique et le la
carte de fond ce qui fait que la
Californie c'est une région
méditerranéenne donc dans le bruit il
peut déjà pas beaucoup et donc ce que
les projections montrent dans le futur
si encore une fois si on ne fait rien
c'est que ces régions là encore moins
d'eau là dessus ce superpose cette
variation décennale et en ce moment et
des eaux plutôt chaudes au large de la
Californie dans le Pacifique Nord qui
sont là depuis quelques années qui
renforcent cet effet là et maintenant
une ligne qui va venir là au contraire
apporter des précipitations
décennale du Pacifique va donc se
poursuivre sur plusieurs années mais ces
répercussions sont en train de s'effacer
au profit de celle d'aniño qui prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur
cet hiver on prévoit au contraire
beaucoup de précipitations en Californie
et cela pourrait mettre un terme à cette
sécheresse on
ignore si un seul hiver humide suffira à
restaurer les niveaux d'eau mais toutes
les prévisions s'accordent sur un hiver
très pluvieux en Californie
le bilan de ses feux est catastrophique
c'est la plus terrible saison sèche
depuis 10 ans aux États-Unis
31600 km² ont brûlé dans différents
États au sud et à l'ouest du pays
l'équivalent de la surface de la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur parti en
fumée en quelques mois
six personnes ont trouvé la mort dans
les flammes dont deux pompiers
17000 habitants ont dû être déplacés
pour éviter qu'ils ne soient pris au
piège dans les incendies les pertes
économiques sont estimées à 3 milliards
de dollars un très lourd tribu pour cet
état riche
c'est donc le deuxième cataclysme le
plus grave de cette année 2015
juste avant celui qui s'est produit au
Népal
[Musique]
enclavé entre l'un de la Chine le Népal
un petit pays montagneux grand commun
quart de la France avec toutefois
l'équivalent de la moitié de la
population française dont un million
d'habitants vit dans la capitale 4 - 12
[Musique]
le Népal fait partie des 10 pays les
plus pauvres au monde la population est
installée à proximité des cours d'eau et
des forrestres massivement pour le bois
de chauffage et cultivé du riz
dans les régions montagneuses aucun
arbre ne retient plus alors les blocs de
pierres au-dessus des villages qui
bourdonnent au rythme du petit commerce
selon la religion hindouiste dominante
les Népalais célèbres dans les temples
millénaires le rythme du monde
[Musique]
une danse composée de périodes de
création de conservation et de
destruction une danse sans fin
et la science ne les contredit pas les
géologues comme Yann Klinger retrace
l'origine mouvementée du Népal
la tectonique des plaques dans cette
région ça veut dire que l'un de monte à
une vitesse de 4 cm par an les plaques
de la croûte terrestre elles elles sont
un peu coincées donc elle se déforme
difficilement et cette convergence des
deux plaques
induit de la déformation de la plaque
supérieure la plaque eurasienne et donc
on fabrique des chaînes de montagnes ont
compris la croûte terrestre et on
fabrique des reliefs en fait les deux
plaques elle frottent elles sont
coincées donc pendant que ça pousse
derrière là ici ça coin ça s'accumule et
un moment la croûte dépasse le seuil de
résistance et lâche et donc là on
produit un tremblement de terre qui
permet le relâchement
de la tension à cumulée sur les plaques
les forces et ça ça produit le
tremblement de terre
le dernier séisme géant au Népal remonte
à 1934
8,3 sur l'échelle de Richter
en 2014 Yann Klinger et son équipe
publie une étude selon laquelle le
séisme de 1934 serait annonciateur d'un
autre séisme imminent sur cette faille
va leur donner raison
[Musique]
le 25 avril 2015 un tremblement de terre
de magnitude 7,9 sur l'échelle de
Richter frappe le Népal sur plus de 200
km de part et d'autre de la capitale
Katmandou
je mets tant d'énergie dans le système
un séisme une magnitude 8 va libérer à
peu près autant donc aujourd'hui où
est-ce qu'on a libéré ou est-ce qu'on a
pas libéré donc quels sont les zones qui
ont besoin de libérer quels sont les
zones qui ont moins besoin de libérer en
faisant ce travail on avait
effectivement pointé la zone qui a rompu
comme étant une des zones qui étaient
prêtes à rompre
Jean-Louis Munier est également géologue
il s'est rendu au Népal juste après le
séisme pour positionner des récepteurs
GPS afin de mesurer d'éventuelles
nouveaux mouvements du sol
certaines zones de l'Himalaya comme la
zone juste au nord de Katmandou est
monté de presque d'un mètre
à peu près une minute en fait puisque le
tremblement de terre durée de l'ordre de
la minute dans d'autres zones
paradoxalement
l'Himalaya est un peu descendu par
exemple les plus hauts sommets de
l'Himalaya sans momentanément descendu
un petit peu
le séisme cause directement la mort de
plus de 8000 personnes
qui se tremblement de terre était
envisageable par les géologues
impossible en revanche de prédire avec
précision son arrivée
la façon dont on a procédé et c'est
effectivement de regarder les séismes
historiques
essayer de comprendre la taille de ces
séismes historiques au vu des
destructions les séismes catastrophiques
donc de magnitude 8 ou plus ont des
temps de retour qui sont probablement de
plusieurs centaines d'années
pas loin de 700 800 ans pour ce qu'on en
comprend mais par dessus ça vous venez
rajouter des séismes qui cassent que de
façon partielle et qui reviennent
par-dessus ce cycle
au dessus de l'épicentre les villages de
pierre sont totalement rasés par la
violence du choc qui tue une centaine
d'habitants
les survivants sont réduits à l'errance
[Musique]
fête de la pleine lune
je faisais chauffer comme maintenant de
l'alcool de riz à la mire qu'on appelle
ici le Rachi
[Musique]
autour de moi dans le village tout a
brûlé tout s'est écroulé
on a eu peur des répliques alors on
s'est réfugiés dans les champs
après le tremblement de terre on est
resté trois jours dans les champs avec
les animaux sans manger
heureusement des amis des autres
villages sont arrivés avec des habits et
de la nourriture
aujourd'hui on a plus rien mais il faut
bien continuer à vivre
maintenant on vit là-haut dans les
pâturages dans un camp de maison
construite à la hâte avec des bâches
ce ne sont que des abris temporaires
mais je ne sais pas où nous habitons
demain
le séisme de 2015 a été une catastrophe
au départ mais en même temps c'est que
il s'est produit samedi un jour de beau
temps en fin de matinée alors que toutes
les populations rurales étaient au champ
que les enfants n'étaient pas en classe
mais c'était plutôt en train de jouer
dehors ce séisme ce serait produit dans
la nuit ou un jour où les enfants
étaient à l'école
il aurait été beaucoup plus
catastrophique
dans les jours qui ont suivi plus d'une
centaine de petites répliques ont secoué
le Népal dont un forséisme 7,3 sur
l'échelle de Richter
[Musique]
une autre menace guette désormais les
villages
l'arrivée de la mousson
[Musique]
la plus tombe sans discontinue l'eau est
inexorablement attirée vers le centre de
la Terre
tant qu'elle Russell en surface elle ne
fait que raviner les sols et transforme
les routes en bourbier
mais quand les eaux de pluie
s'engouffrent dans les brèches ouvertes
par le tremblement de terre elle
provoque d'importants glissement de
terrain
et à l'échelle d'une Népal un glissement
de terrain s’est un pont entier de
montagne qui s'effondre
[Musique]
juste avant la mousson vous avez secoué
la bassine si je fais une gamelle et
donc vous avez un certain nombre de
pente qui sont potentiellement
déstabilisés et quand vous chargez le
système avec de l'eau donc c'est à dire
que d'abord vous alourdissez le matériel
vous allez ouvrir les fissures parce que
vous mettez de l'eau dedans vous allez
provoquer des disques de terrain qui
sinon auraient probablement eu lieu mais
aurait été étalé dans le temps en fait
durant la moussant comme la lame d'eau
qui tombe sur l'Himalaya et de plusieurs
mètres il y a une masse énorme dos qui
se dépose sur la chaîne himalayenne et
elle crée des petits séismes qu'on peut
instrumenter mais c'est des petits
séismes qui n'ont pas du tout la même
magnitude que les grands séismes
himalayens
ce village a été littéralement balayé
par un glissement de terrain et noyé
sous une coulée de bout 24 morts
s'ajoutent aux victimes du tremblement
de terre dans le nombre a été porté à
ça c'était ma maison
les pluies ont tout emporté
et à une heure du matin
il pleuvait très fort et le terrain a
glissé
ensuite le glissement de terrain a
entraîné la chute de 13 maisons
de 25 personnes à tenter d'aider
quelqu'un dont la maison était ensevelie
mais ils n'ont pas pu entrer
la période de la mousson est la saison
la plus prolifique pour l'agriculture à
condition que les terrains ne s'effondre
pas en emportant bêtes et culture
[Musique]
en aval quels ont été les dégâts
provoqués à katmandous la capitale
surpeuplée du départ
un million d'habitants installés dans
une cuvette sur les dépôts argileux d'un
lac préhistorique
l'amplitude des ondes sismiques augmente
en traversant l'interface roche dure sol
argileux
les maisons traditionnelles en briques
ou en pierre n'ont pas résisté au
secours
seuls les habitations récentes en béton
armés sont encore debout pour peu que
les ferraillages relient murs et
plancher porteur
dans le cas contraire les étages
inférieurs qui portent tout le poids du
bâtiment s'effondre si vous allez sur le
terrain on n'est pas j'y suis allé juste
après
toutes les maisons loin de là n'étaient
pas par terre mais la plupart étaient
fortement endommagée et donc à laisser
fonder en tout cas n'était plus
utilisable elle s'effondre pas le jour
du tremblement de terre mais elles sont
fissurées fracturées et elles attendent
un petit quelque chose de plus pour
s'effondrer
au total le séisme a provoqué 10
milliards de dollars de destruction soit
la moitié du PIB du pays un coup
exorbitant pour le Népal
pour chercher des survivants dans ces
décombres les secours historistes
risquent leur dire ils recréent des
accès dans les planchers qui menacent de
s'effondrer à tout moment
en intervenant dans les jours qui
suivent le séisme les secouristes
sauvent la vie de centaines de victimes
pour ces survivants le tremblement reste
un traumatisme
c'est extrêmement difficile de raconter
ce séisme avec des mots j'étais dehors
quand ça s'est produit et le premier
tremblement venait de l'ouest en
direction de l'est
mon portail a été secoué d'au moins un
mètre à l'Est puis à l'ouest ma femme
mes enfants et ma mère étaient à
l'intérieur de la maison j'ai essayé de
rentrer mais la porte tremblait
tellement que je ne pouvais absolument
pas l'ouvrir
la rue au dehors est pavée de petites
tuiles il y a eu un rondissement comme
si un serpent monstrueux avançait sous
mes pieds
je crois que c'était à des moments les
plus effrayants de ma vie je pensais que
j'étais mort
selon la philosophie hindouiste les
séismes incarnent ce troisième et
terrible pas de la danse du monde
construction conservation destruction
parmi tous les cataclysmes naturels le
séisme est le plus compliqué à prévoir
on sait qu'il est inéluctable mais rien
ne permet aujourd'hui de l'anticiper
pour le volcanisme on sait on sait qu'il
y a certains signes annonciateurs qu'on
est capable de mesurer par exemple des
petits séismes qui se produisent quand
le magma est en train de monter dans
dans la chambre aujourd'hui pour les
séismes on ne connaît pas de signes
précurseurs seul certitude les mesures
effectuées sur le terrain par l'équipe
de Jean-Louis Munier révèle qu'une
partie de la force accumulée entre les
deux plaques n'a pas été relâché
comme celui de cette année il a pas tout
donné ça on est déjà sûr parce que
nos études montrent que il a glissé sur
une partie entre le nord de la chaîne
jusqu'à Katmandou et entre quatre -2 et
la plaine en fait le chevauchement est
resté bloqué
un deuxième séisme pourrait donc se
produire avec des conséquences
potentiellement encore plus
catastrophiques si on imagine que ma
main représente la plaque indienne qui
s'enfonce ici on a la trace du contact à
la surface c'est à dire ça c'est l'Inde
ça c'est ce qui est dessous
et le séisme qui a rompu en 2015 c'est
une section assez profonde déjà ce qui
reste à casser aujourd'hui au moins pour
cette partie du front c'est la partie
qui vient de l'endroit qui a cassé
jusqu'à la surface
et ça ça fait encore 100 km
on pourrait s'attendre à avoir un autre
séisme important avec des conséquences
oui très destructives entre quelques
mois et quelques années nul ne peut le
prédire mais les regards de la
communauté scientifique restent fixés
sur le Népal en prévision de cette
réplique annoncée
malgré cette compilation terrifiante de
colère du ciel et de la terre le bilan
de cette année 2015 est-il
particulièrement édifiant en termes de
catastrophes naturelles
pas forcément en tout cas sur le plan
économique d'après Robert new wood qui
modélise les risques pour les compagnies
d'assurance
on peut mesurer le coût total planétaire
des catastrophes naturelles en estimant
les pères
c'est probablement autour d'une centaine
de milliards d'euros tout ensemble ou
dans cet ordre d'idée
un impact économique ça c'est juste pour
une année moyenne et je ne sais pas
encore pour cette année mais je pense
que nous serons en dessous de cette
moyenne
dans des lieux comme Taïwan par exemple
il y a beaucoup d'assurance et il y a eu
des pertes cette année mais il y a très
peu d'assurance au Népal par exemple
parce que c'est un pays pauvre
donc globalement cette année a été très
calme en termes de risque d'assurance
même son de cloche du côté des
spécialistes des volcans à l'heure du
bilan malgré quelques épisodes
spectaculaires 2015 n'a pas d'effrayé la
chronique
c'était une année assez calme il y a eu
le calbucco et le barbe à bunga qui a
terminé son éruption ça a donné un peu
de temps aux scientifiques pour analyser
toutes les données qu'ils avaient
accumulées c'est une très bonne année
quand il ne se passe pas grand chose
enfin pour les cyclones le bilan de
cette année 2015 est plus mitigé en
fonction des zones géographiques
au niveau mondial le nombre des cyclones
tropicaux est assez stable avec environ
86 systèmes par an
en revanche sur l'Atlantique l'année
2015 a été particulièrement calme si on
se réfère à l'ordre alphabétique utilisé
pour nommer les cyclones qui
apparaissent l'un après l'autre
quand il y a un igno donc avec des
anomalies de température chaudes dans
l'est du Pacifique en général l'activité
cyclonique sur l'Atlantique et affaiblie
à titre d'exemple l'année 2005 qui était
une année record on a été jusqu'à Z et
puis une fois arrivé à Z on attaque les
lettres de l'alphabet alphabeta gamma
delta et je crois qu'on est allé jusqu'à
enfin on a eu 31 phénomènes dans l'année
2005 ce qui est un record absolu
puisqu'en moyenne on a une dizaine dans
l'Atlantique de phénomènes donc l'année
2005 à être voilà c'est pour vous donner
une fourchette aujourd'hui on est à J et
en 2005 on a attaqué les lettres de
l'alphabet grec ce calme apparent ne
doit pas endormir la vigilance des
scientifiques en effet elle Niño est
loin d'avoir dit son dernier mot c'est
au tour de Noël que le phénomène
surnommé El ninio comme l'Enfant-Jésus
donne toute sa mesure c'est normal que
pour l'instant on n'est pas eu des
anomalies très marquées au niveau
climatique mondial le Nino est en face
de de sont faites et on atteindra le
maximum aux alentours de Noël donc le
début de l'année 2015 on avait une très
faible anomalie de température sur
l'océan Pacifique la phase de croissance
c'est seulement maintenant et les
conséquences à venir d'union ne se
limiterait pas au sol Pacifique ce
mécanisme météorologique est l'un des
plus puissants moteurs de changement du
climat mondial c'est pas du tout aussi
localisé qui pourrait y paraître vu de
l'Europe en fait c'est que au niveau des
tropiques on a déjà la moitié de la
surface du globe qui se trouve entre 30
degrés Nord et 32°c en plus l'océan
Pacifique c'est vraiment un monstre au
niveau au niveau
océan sur la planète
puisqu'on a 17000 km des côtes de
l'Amérique du Sud jusqu'à aux
Philippines de l'autre côté
[Musique]
pluie diluvienne sécheresse devrait
dérèglements pourrait affecter notre
planète dans les mois à venir parfois à
des milliers de kilomètres de la zone où
l'anomalie climatique a commencé
il va y avoir des énormes inondations
sur la côte du Pérou et de la Bolivie
par exemple alors qu'une sécheresse va
servir dans le nord-est du Brésil ou
encore une autre en Australie
la corrélation de ces événements est
clairement dû à une idiot
il y a beaucoup de phénomènes qui en
sont liés et on peut s'attendre à de
nombreux autres dans les prochains mois
le dernier El Niño record s'est produit
en 97 98 avec deux degrés 7 par rapport
à la normale les dégâts qu'il avait
provoqué ont été estimés à 33 milliards
de dollars
fin 2015 elle n'ignore frôle déjà la
barre des trois degrés ce qui permet au
climatologue d'entrevoir les grandes
tendances météorologiques à venir
2015 et 2016 une grande certitude vont
être des années records de chaleur par
contre 2017 sera froid puisque en
général après une ligne où il y a la
ligne
qui est refroidissement du Pacifique qui
est un peu le retour de balancier par
contre sur les canicules si on prend les
canicules en France là on est à peu près
certain que sans réduire le
réchauffement climatique en cours on va
vers plus de canicule aujourd'hui on a 2
à 3 jours de canicule par an en France
on va arriver à 20 30 jours de canicule
par an ça on a assez confiance
au niveau des tempêtes et leur impact de
précipitation aujourd'hui la recherche
est pas suffisamment lancée pour pouvoir
le dire de façon certaine
ce scénario climatique est encore
toutefois modifiable à condition de
prendre d'importantes décisions
politiques pour modifier le niveau des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
limiter le réchauffement
malgré un grand nombre de catastrophes
naturelles 2015 n'a pas été aussi
dramatique qu'on pourrait le croire
certains événements à imprévisibles
comme le tremblement de terre au Népal
ont gravement marqué l'année
d'autres plus faciles à surveiller comme
le volcanisme sont à peu près rester
sous contrôle
[Musique]
en revanche au niveau météorologique
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour en faire une année explosive
elle n'ignore record réchauffement
climatique et oscillation décennale du
Pacifique se sont combinés pour faire
grimper le thermomètre et détraquer
pluie et sécheresse
[Musique]
attention ces phénomènes n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot et 2016 pourrait bien
commencer enfin
[Musique]
2016 a marqué la fin de l'événement
elnio un des plus puissants jamais
enregistré
il a provoqué des crues sans précédent
en Amérique du Sud
[Musique]
sans lien direct de terribles
inondations se produisent en Europe du
Nord
mais cela allait changer du tout au tout
quelques mois plus tard alors que la
planète connaissait le mois d'août le
plus chaud depuis le début des relevés
des sécheresses extrêmes dans plusieurs
régions du globe firent naître de
graffeux de forêt
[Musique]
les températures élevées à la surface
des océans alimentaires de violentes
tempêtes dans l'Atlantique et le
Pacifique
pour la première fois nous avons subi
sur l'Atlantique de violences ouragan en
même temps ce qui ne s'était jamais vu
nous pouvons prévoir ces tempêtes mais
il nous est toujours impossible
d'anticiper l'une des catastrophes
naturelles les plus meurtrières sur
terre le tremblement de terre
nous avons constaté de nombreuses
catastrophes moyennes qui sont
susceptibles de coûter des dizaines et
des dizaines de milliards de dollars
utilisant des images tournées par des
professionnels dans le feu de l'action
ce film présente les principales
catastrophes naturelles survenues en
2016 des moins funestes au plus
tragiques
[Musique]
dans le sud de la France l'été 2016
restera dans les mémoires comme la
saison la plus sèche jamais enregistrée
la pluviométrie est la plus faible
relevée depuis 1950 avec en juillet et
août seulement 60 mm d'eau tombée en
moyenne
en Provence ce chiffre est nul pas une
goutte de pluie n'est tombée pendant
l'été
conséquence les lacs de la région
véritable oasis pour les hommes et les
animaux non plus été alimentés par les
rivières et les cours d'eau desséchés
[Musique]
voici à quoi ces mêmes rivières
ressemblaient au mois d'août 2015
[Musique]
cette pénurie en eau conjuguée à de très
fortes chaleurs fait drastiquement
baisser les niveaux d'humidité dans le
sol
preuve en est la situation du lac de
Besse-sur-Issole dans le Var qui pour la
première fois de son histoire s'est
retrouvé complètement à sec
ou presque
voici à quoi le lac devrait ressembler
et voici ce qu'il est devenu à l'été
[Musique]
la végétation stressée et desséchée par
ses conditions extrêmes et fragilisées à
la moindre petite étincelle elle
s'enflamme
pire un ingrédient fatal vient parfois
s'ajouter à la liste des agressions le
vent
plus connu localement sous le nom de
Mistral ce vent violent assèche les
ambiants
[Musique]
le mistral attise le feu dans des
proportions inimaginables des flammes de
plusieurs dizaines de mètres carbonisent
instantanément arbres et plantes et
coupe les routes
[Musique]
le 10 août 1500 pompiers furent appelés
pour combattre un immense feu près de
Vitrolles aux portes de Marseille
ce bâtir au sol et dans les airs
mais la nuit impossible pour les
canadairs de se repérer et donc de voler
à vue seuls les divisions de pompiers au
sol peuvent continuer le combat
[Musique]
en première ligne les rafales de vent
poussent les flammes à des vitesses de
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres par
heure
[Musique]
la chaleur est-elle que même les racines
des plantes sont réduites ensemble
[Musique]
au total 2016 restera une année record
sur le front des incendies le bilan est
lourd 355 départs de feu et près de 5000
hectares brûlés rien que dans le
département des Bouches-du-Rhône
aucune victime n'est à déplorer mais le
coût total des dommages n'est pas loin
d'atteindre les 3 millions d'euros
conséquence indirecte le potentiel de
croissance des arbres survivants est
affaibli pendant plusieurs années
infestée par les insectes soumis aux
aléas climatiques certains finiront par
périr des mois après l'incendie
ils laisseront la place au pain
mais dans certains endroits la fréquence
des feux empêche les pins de parvenir à
maturité sexuelle les arbres
disparaissent progressivement remplacées
par une végétation de Gary
ces surfaces brûlées restent cependant
dérisoires
en comparaison de celles ravagées par le
gigantesque incendie qui a frappé la
région de Fort McMurray au Canada au
mois de mai
le feu a démarré au sud-ouest de Forem
McMurray le 1er mai mais le 3 il avait
déjà dévasté la communauté et faisait
rage sur l'autoroute 63 forçant des
dizaines de milliers de personnes à
évacuer les lieux en urgence
ce fut la plus importante évacuation due
à un incendie de toute l'histoire de
l'État d'albertin
[Musique]
l'incendie de Vinci important qu'il se
transforma en véritable tempête avec
foudre et vent violent
près de 600 000 hectares de forêt et
environ 2500 habitations partir en fumée
de façon assez incroyable il n'est
aucune victime directe du feu mais à ce
jour cet incendie reste la catastrophe
naturelle la plus coûteuse de l'histoire
du Canada avec un montant de dommage
assuré atteignant les quatre virgule 7
milliards de dollars
[Musique]
une telle catastrophe est-elle
directement liée au réchauffement
climatique
si la saison sèche dure plus longtemps
en particulier après un hiver plus vieux
et que la végétation fournit un bon
combustible on peut avoir de gros feux
de forêt et quand le vent dépasse une
certaine vitesse il n'y a rien que vous
puissiez faire pour stopper un incendie
on a connu cette situation en Californie
il y a quelques années on a vu ça en
Grèce au Portugal dans le sud de la
France on a vu ça au printemps dernier
au Canada
on avait simplement qu'à attendre que le
vent change de direction ou bien qu'il
fasse refluer le feu pour l'éteindre
c'est ce que nous avons connu cette
année et il faut s'attendre à de plus en
plus d'événements de ce type
particulièrement sur le ponton
méditerranéen qui se réchauffe et sa
sèche de plus en plus
dans l'hémisphère sud le climat a
également provoqué une catastrophe
d'ampleur inhabituel plus précisément à
assuntion la capitale du Paraguay qui
s'étend sur les rives du fleuve du même
nom depuis décembre 2015 des plus
diluviennes se sont abattus sur les
bassins versants du fleuve Paraguay et
de fortes précipitations entraînées par
un puissant et Nino font monter le
niveau des cours d'eau au Paraguay en
Argentine en Uruguay et au Brésil mais
caisse exactement quel ninio
l'évéo qui doit son nom à la période à
laquelle il arrive et qui correspond un
peu à Noël et le nom de Jésus-Christ en
espagnol El Nino ce phénomène cyclique
commence quand les eaux chaudes de
l'océan Pacifique occidental tropicales
se déplace vers l'est le long de
l'équateur en direction des côtes
d'Amérique du Sud
les eaux de surface chaudes du Pacifique
restent alors près des côtes
l'augmentation de ces températures dans
l'est du bassin Pacifique décale
l'activité des pluies dans l'est du
bassin donc donne des anomalies de pluie
et peut donner des événements très
pluvieux accompagnés d'inondations sur
la côte est de l'Amérique du Sud
[Musique]
début janvier à assuncion les crues ont
contraint plus de 150 000 personnes à
abandonner leur foyer
à différents endroits la capitale a
connu de graves inondations depuis le
mois de novembre
à la mi-décembre le niveau du fleuve
Paraguay avait déjà atteint 6 mètres 50
son plus haut niveau de toute l'année
largement supérieur au seuil déjà
critique de 5 mètres 50
beaucoup redoutaient le pire
des milliers de personnes ont été
évacuées des quartiers situés le long de
la rivière quand le niveau du fleuve a
atteint les 7 mètres 84 le 7 janvier
est plus intense
c'est un lieu où le fleuve grandissant
cesse
et dernièrement il est devenu
incontrôlable
je n'ai pas pu venir jusqu'ici
aujourd'hui j'ai fait un effort pour
venir pour mon père
comment voilà vous voyez ce n'est pas
facile d'accès
c'est une zone extrêmement inondable
à cause de la pluie venant du Brésil
d'Argentine
car cela implique beaucoup de sacrifices
les gens pensent toujours que c'est la
dernière fois
cependant cela se reproduit toujours
l'histoire se répète les gens se mettent
à reconstruire et ils ont à peine le
temps de finir que cela recommence et
tout est emporté
mon père a toute sa vie ici ces animaux
sa famille il ne veut pas partir
près de 6000 familles ont été touchées
dans les premières semaines de décembre
après que le niveau du fleuve a franchi
la barre des 7 mètres le nombre des
victimes à doubler
13000 familles furent victimes des
inondations la plupart d'entre elles
originaire de Los banianos le quartier
pauvre de la ville situé tout proche du
fleuve
[Musique]
le gouvernement paraguayen déclara
l'état d'urgence à assuncian ainsi que
dans cet autre région du pays
pareillement affecté
le phénomène El Niño se produit de
manière aléatoire à peu près tous les
deux à 7 ans et dure de 12 à 18 mois
engendrant des risques répétés
d'inondation dans les zones exposées et
la menace d'épidémie de choléra et de
paludisme
elle est d'abord montée petit à petit et
puis c'est venu d'un coup
ça s'est passé comme ça en 74 ou 75
cette année nous avons été inondé deux
fois l'eau est montée jusqu'au mur la
marque est arrivée quasiment à 9 mètres
nous sommes prêts à rester parce que
j'aime ma vie ici le problème c'est la
salle de bain la lumière et les maladies
pas moins de 200 pilonnes électriques
ont été détruits par les pluies
torrentielles laissant des milliers de
foyers sans électricité
quatre personnes ont trouvé la mort
victime de chutes d'arbres dans ce qui
fut considéré comme les pires
inondations depuis un demi-siècle
[Musique]
le montant total des dégâts est estimé à
3,5 millions de dollars
[Musique]
quelques mois plus tard c'est encore un
phénomène météorologique exceptionnel
qui s'est produit en Europe
en mai 2016 un système de haute pression
était stationnaire au-dessus de l'Europe
septentrionale entraînant un temps sec
et beau pendant que tout le cœur de
l'Europe était sous le couvert de basse
pression elles aussi stationnaires
cela provoqua des pluies
beaucoup de pluie
de violones averses fin mai et début
juin causèrent de sérieux problèmes sur
tout le nord de l'Europe en particulier
en France et en Allemagne
en France ce sont quelques-unes des
pires inondations depuis un siècle qui
ont été recensés
dans certaines régions c'est
l'équivalent de six semaines de pluie
qui est tombé en trois jours
les événements qu'on a connus cet été
font partie du cycle naturel même si ce
sont des événements rares et extrêmes et
dramatique il ne reste pas moins qu'il
faut partir des cycles naturels on peut
pas les attribuer ni au réchauffement
climatique ni à une igno
à Paris au tout début du mois de juin la
scène atteint des niveaux inégalés
depuis près de 30 ans
depuis 200 ans la statue du zouave sous
le pont de l'Alma est la mesure
symbolique du niveau de la Seine pour
les parisiens
le niveau du fleuve à grimpé jusqu'à 6
mètres 10
c'est la plus importante inondation dans
la capitale depuis 1982 quand les os
étaient montés jusqu'à 6 mètres 18
mais elles n'ont pas atteint le niveau
de la crue historique de 1910 8 mètres
l'élévation du niveau de l'eau a conduit
plusieurs musées dont le Louvre et le
musée d'Orsay a déplacé quelques-unes de
leur collection pour les mettre à l'abri
et les transports publics à prendre des
précautions pour le métro notamment
la RATP a mis en pratique des procédures
d'urgence visant à fermer la circulation
au train lorsque le niveau de la scène
atteint 5 mètres 10
l'inondation à Paris a été provoqué par
de très violentes précipitations dans
l'Est de la France
autre victime de ces déluge un monument
français bien connu le château de
Chambord
il s'est retrouvé les pieds dans l'eau
lorsque la rivière Cosson est sortie de
son lit au même moment que Paris était
inondé
la cour royale et le parterre du château
de François 1er furent totalement
submergé
on a vu qu'on avait affaire un événement
au conséquences imprévisibles on a
évacué certaines maisons qui commencent
à être inondées un pavillon forestier
une injitre rurale une maison en bordure
du
monument le lendemain matin donc
mercredi on a coupé l'électricité dans
les parties basses du château parce
qu'en fait là où normalement c'est vide
il y avait un mètre 50 d'eau qui avait
monté en fait le niveau des douves sous
se sont retrouvés sous la cour
que ce château a été merveilleusement
construit et par ailleurs le donjon à
côté duquel on est et bien en fait il
est rehaussé de un être par rapport au
sol donc il était calculé sans doute par
rapport au cru qu'on pouvait observer
dans le cochon c'est un une œuvre de
génie et c'est quand même assez lucinant
et assez émouvant de voir que cinq
siècles après il résiste à un épisode
météorologique
au moins centenal et en tout cas sans
précédent connu
non loin de Chambord à Tours en Sologne
la crue a atteint maître 60 les gens ont
été surpris en pleine nuit par la montée
des eaux
heureusement mon frère mangeait chez ma
mère et il a dit donc il avait vu deux
trois centimètres à 10h du soir de 3 cm
d'eau il a dit bon bah on va on va
surélever les meubles ils ont tout mis
sur cales ils ont essayé de sauver des
trucs allez ils ont mis des choses à
l'étage
ils ont dit bon bah donc ma mère est
allée dormir chez mon frère heureusement
79 ans chose que José le voisin n'a pas
eu enfin il a pas eu cette chance là il
s'est réveillé les pieds dans l'eau quoi
le livre
bon bah la voiture la Super 5
elle est plus tellement super
tout le monde s'est fait surprendre là
on a rien pu sauver rien du tout ça
c'est jamais arrivé ma mère 80 ans donc
à jamais vu ça de sa mémoire ça s'est
jamais vu quoi et jamais eu des crues
enfin une cru comme ça c'est ici c'est
extraordinaire
pour les agriculteurs de la région les
inondations ont des conséquences
désastreuses
on s'imagine pas trop qu'il y a un champ
de maïs
c'est un beau lac au carré
les pompiers sont arrivés ils ont dit il
faut absolument évacuer sinon tout le
monde va mourir donc là il fait de
panique on avait quand même de l'eau à
90 cm c'était c'était quand même assez
dur quand on est arrivé au bout et on
s'est dit en fait on peut se faire
piéger très très rapidement par l'eau on
savait pas ce qu'il pouvait se passer
et là on a eu peur on a pris conscience
de la crue quoi vraiment l'eau elle a
une puissante
extraordinaire et avec le courant on
s'est dit que finalement on pouvait vite
se faire piéger
et deux jours après voilà ça m'a
vraiment coupé les pattes quoi on est
revenu sur la ferme et là on voit
l'étendue des dégâts on voit que
que le blé en fait l'eau est passé au
dessus des épis donc ça veut dire qu'il
y aura rien il y aura pas de récolte et
sur le jardin c'est pareil l'année
dernière on avait noyé un tout petit peu
là c'est tout était sous l'eau donc les
fraises elles sont formées il y avait
des fraises rouges des fraises des
fraises déjà formées
quelques jours sous l'eau
il y a pas besoin de d'être agriculteur
pour savoir que ça présage rien de bon
des crues tardives comme ça c'est très
rare quoi au niveau du Cosson pour moi
c'est une crucente
quatre personnes sont mortes et 42 ont
été blessés dans tout le pays le coup
des inondations en France fut estimé à
800 millions d'euros
de telles tempêtes des climats tempérés
sont moins structurés moins
spectaculaires et moins meurtrière que
les tempêtes tropicales
le climat change l'atmosphère se
réchauffe ce qui entraîne aussi le
réchauffement de l'océan et des Océans
chauds sont le carburant idéal pour les
ouragans et les typhons
Taïwan a été particulièrement touchée
par les typhones cette année de récentre
recherche s'accorde à souligner que le
pouvoir destructeur de ces tempêtes a
augmenté de 50% lors des 40 dernières
années
en 2016 la saison des typhons dans le
Pacifique a démarré tardivement par la
première tempête tropicale nommée
nepartak qui a ouvert les hostilités le
3 juillet seulement
à ses débuts ce n'était qu'une zone de
basse pression au dessus de l'archipel
oriental des Carolines reclassée en
typhon le 5 juillet
avec des eaux à plus de 30 degrés dans
toute la mer des Philippines mais par
tac a été requalifié en super typhon le
soir du 5 juillet atteignant son
intensité maximale à l'approche de
tahitung sur la côte sud-est de Taïwan
avec une pression de 900 mg et des vents
de plus de 200 km heure
les parcs traversent la Taïwan le 7
juillet
[Musique]
il y a de grandes montagnes et très peu
de personnes vivent à l'Est
l'activité économique les grandes villes
presque toute la population et les
bâtiments sont concentrés sur le côté
ouest de l'île la région des plaines est
la plupart des typhons arrivent d'un axe
sud-est donc ils ont tendance à toucher
d'abord les montagnes mais partage à
causé trois décès sur l'île mais allait
provoquer la mort de 83 personnes en
Chine et un milliard et demi de dollars
de dommages au total
trois mois plus tard un second typhon
frappe à Taiwan
baptisé merenti il a été évalué comme le
cyclone tropical le plus puissant au
monde sur l'année 2016 et l'un des
cyclones tropicaux les plus violents
jamais enregistrés
la tempête s'est formée à l'ouest de
Guam dans la partie occidentale de
l'océan Pacifique le 11 septembre elle
est requalifiée en typhon s'intensifie
rapidement le 12 septembre et devient un
super typhon de catégorie 5 avec des
vents soutenus enregistrées à plus de
240 km/h et une pression atmosphérique
de 890 mg
mais rendu ravagea l'extrême sud de
Taïwan
[Musique]
deux personnes périr et plus de 700 000
habitations se retrouvèrent sans eau et
sans électricité la tempête continua à
détruire près de 300 habitations aux
Philippines et causent à la mort de 30
personnes dans les inondations qui s'en
sont suivies en Chine
le 21 septembre près de guaham encore
une dépression tropicale se forma elle
se transforme en typhon le 23 septembre
Meggie
il atteignait l'intensité maximale d'un
typhon de catégorie 3 cette fois sur
l'île même frappant de plein fouet la
ville de wallienne sur la côte est
pacifique de Taïwan avec des vents
soutenues de plus de 160 km/h et une
pression atmosphérique de 940 millibar
lorsque Meggy sabattit sur la côte des
vagues gigantesques déferlèrent causant
l'une des pires pannes générales de
toute l'histoire de l'île et laissant
plus de 3 millions de foyers sans
électricité
toutefois contrairement à ce que la
taille des vagues aurait pu laisser
craindre les dégâts ne furent pas aussi
catastrophiques que prévu
le dernier de ces typhon entraîna des
vitesses de vent plutôt élevées des
vitesses de vent qui dans beaucoup de
pays auraient été fort dommageable
à Taïwan en particulier sur le port
principal de KAOS Yang le typhon entre
na des vents très violents mais ne causa
pas de très grands dommages parce que
les bâtiments à Taïwan sont très bien
conçus
[Musique]
alors que l’œil de la tempête traversait
l'île les vents changèrent de direction
mais Guy oblige à plus de 14000
personnes à être évacuées des zones
montagneuses près de la côte vers les
centres d'urgence
91 personnes perdirent la vie et le
total des dommages de ces typhon si
destructeur a été estimé à 1,25
milliards de dollars
[Musique]
les chercheurs alertent sur le fait que
ces énormes tempêtes vont devenir bien
plus puissantes dans le futur menaçant
les populations côtières sans cesse
croissantes des pays du Pacifique
ces habitants font également face à des
épreuves bien plus sournoises
oui CV on peut voir les catastrophes la
majeure partie des catastrophes les
catastrophes qui sont à la une des
journaux et on peut estimer le coût des
dégâts causés par la plus grosse
catastrophe connue mais il y a aussi ce
que l'on appelle des risques insidieux
des catastrophes insidieuses quand les
choses bougent lentement qui ont le sait
ont déjà commencé à causer beaucoup de
pertes et qui vont causer encore plus de
pertes dans le futur
et le plus important d'entre elles est
la montée du niveau de la mer qui monte
de 3 mm chaque année à présent
l'une des estimations que l'on a des
conséquences de la hausse du niveau de
la mer c'est une estimation de 2006 qui
est évaluée à un triom c'est-à-dire un
million de millions de dollars les
risques si le niveau de la mer s'élève à
1 mètre
c'est lavant c'est parce que si vous
réfléchissez à toutes les
infrastructures qui se trouvent au
niveau de la mer sport station
d'épuration hôtel raffinerie
pétrochimiques aéroport toutes ces
choses sont construites juste au-dessus
du niveau de la mer et si le niveau de
la mer monte elles devront être
relocalisées
conséquence directe de la croissance
démographique d'autres événements futurs
vont devenir plus dévastateurs encore
2016 illustre le défi de vivre sur une
planète tectoniquement active
l'océan Pacifique est saturé par un
réseau de failles d'origine tectonique
et de volcans baptisé la ceinture de feu
du Pacifique
au nord-ouest de cette ceinture Ranchu
et cue les îles les plus peuplées du
Japon sont à la jonction de plusieurs
plaques
la plaque océanique des Philippines il
rentre en collision avec plusieurs plats
eurasiennes et créer une faille médiane
qui circule sous les îles du sud-ouest à
l'est
à l'extrémité sud de cette zone de
rupture la préfecture de Kumamoto est
construite sur un mille-feuille de roche
chaque année plusieurs dizaines de
secousses telluriques qui sont ressentis
au moins d'avril 2016 une série de
tremblements de terre a frappé la zone
de Kumamoto avec une secousse principale
de magnitude 7 le 16 avril
l'épicentre du séisme se situait à
quelques centimètres au sud-est de
Sendai sur l'île d'haut à l'endroit où
un tremblement de terre et un tsunami
ont tout dévasté en mars 2011
ne se situait pas sur la plaque de la
zone de subduction mais sur une zone sur
laquelle il y a de nombreuses phases
actives qui courent sur tout le centre
de Kyu
les routes furent terriblement
endommagées entre le 14 et le 20 avril
ce sont plus de 600 répliques sismiques
qui ont été ressentis dont deux
particulièrement fortes
15000 soldats de l'armée japonaise
prirent part aux opérations de secours
dans les jours qui suivirent le
tremblement de terre
la recherche elle sauvetage c'est l'une
de nos priorités majeures
nous sommes frustrés
nous ne pouvons pas y aller pour le
moment
les répliques continuent nous devons
être prudents car la nature ne permet
pas l'optimisme
[Musique]
outre les effondrements de maison et
d'immeubles de nombreux glissements de
terrain se produisirent de l'autre côté
de la chaîne montagneuse de kychu
balafrant les coteaux et provoquant
l'effondrement du grand pont d'assaut
sur la nationale 325 dans la rivière
Kurokawa
[Musique]
de mémoire d'hommes c'est du jamais vu
il y a déjà eu plusieurs glissements de
terrain de grande ampleur 5 ans
auparavant
ils ont été classifiés en tant que
désastre national cela a causé d'énormes
dégâts
je ne suis pas sûr que ceci soit plus
gros comparé au précédent en tout cas il
continue mais de gros rochers qui n'ont
jamais bougé auparavant sont tombés
cette fois
vous pouvez apercevoir sur la montagne
les zones où il y a du sol rouge suite
au glissement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
17 avril le Premier ministre japonais
Shinzo AB mobilisa 3000 soldats de
l'armée de l'air pour permettre aux
autorités locales d'atteindre les zones
sinistrées
[Musique]
et un glissement de terrain d'une telle
ampleur
depuis que je suis arrivé ici nous avons
déjà trouvé quatre personnes
une personne de plus stress introuvable
donc nous allons chercher toute la nuit
c'était une occurrence naturelle et
personne n'a rien vu venir
nous n'avons aucun indice
on ne sait pas où les maisons ont été
emportées
nous faisons des recherches basées sur
des suppositions
le temps presse pour retrouver des
survivants l'équipe se prépare à passer
une nuit blanche
[Musique]
trois personnes il y a ma gauche et
ne sont pas encore ici ils sont déjà
descendus là-bas et sont déjà descendus
en dernier la nôtre c'est tout
maintenant
on descend je vais ouvrir la voie
sommes-nous sur la liste
de personnes oui vous pouvez venir avec
nous
nous laisserons le matériel là où sont
les équipes en attente
n'a pas encore été décidé donc veuillez
le laisser à proximité de la maison
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont été
tirées des décombres
les sauveteurs font l'impossible pour
trouver d'autres survivants avant les
averses prévues et de nouvelles
secousses
le 18 avril 24 personnes ont été
retrouvées sans vie 11 étaient toujours
portés disparus et plus de 91000 ont dû
être évacués
le nombre de personnes à relogées
avaient atteint les 180 000
autres résultats des secousses la ville
entière de Kumamoto se retrouvait d'eau
ne transportant des provisions par le
sol et par les airs avec des
hélicoptères de l'armée japonaise ou
américaine
nous fournissons aussi de l'eau
beaucoup de zones n'ont plus accès à
l'eau courante
préparer des repas avec des provisions
limitées fait partie de notre
entraînement
donc cela fait partie de nos
responsabilités
le 19 avril la peur de nouvelles
répliques pousse à encore plus
d'habitants à élire refuge dans les
voitures les stades et les espaces
ouverts
[Musique]
les autorités gouvernementales ont
estimé à plus de 1000 le nombre
d'immeubles fortement endommagés et à 90
le nombre d'immeubles complètement
détruit
[Musique]
la deuxième fois la maison s'est
effondrée
ça s'est passé à peu près à 1h25 du
matin
c'était comme si mon corps était projeté
de part et d'autre sur environ un mètre
c'était juste là
où il y a la table du salon en dessous
de l'horloge
je dormais en dessous de la table
je pensais que je serai plus en sécurité
et qu'elle me protégerait si quelque
chose tombait sur moi coucou
je suis terrifié à l'idée de savoir ce
qui me serait arrivé si j'avais été dans
ma chambre en bas
la voiture a été écrasée comme une crêpe
[Musique]
par an nous avons eu un tremblement de
terre de magnitude 3 ou 4
je pense que c'était un signe
un signe d'alerte
bien que le foyer du séisme se soit
situé sous le mont kimpu au nord-ouest
du centre ville de Kumamoto les zones
les plus touchées furent machiki et
mikubo dans la banlieue est de Kumamoto
la demeure de satomie Otomo à mi-coubo a
été construite juste sur la ligne de
rupture son avenir reste incertain
faites attention vous mettez les pieds
s'il vous plaît
j'ai peur j'ai vraiment peur de rester
dans ma maison
parce qu'il y a encore de nombreuses
répliques
si je reste à l'intérieur et qu'une
réplique se produit comme cette maison
est déjà toute de travers la maison
pourrait s'effondrer ça me fait très
peur
l'armoire est tombée ici et par là
c'était le chaos
ici cette porte on pouvait plus l'ouvrir
elle était complètement bloquée
quand on a voulu s'échapper il n'y avait
plus que cette petite ouverture pour se
sauver notre unique volonté à ce
moment-là c'était survivre en
s'échappant
la chambre des enfants est de ce côté-là
quand je repense à ce moment
j'étais complètement terrorisée j'avais
très peur
à vaisselle se sont ouverts
et toutes les assiettes et les vers sont
tombés par terre
le frigo était de ce côté là
cette étagère était comme ça mais plus
tourné
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de reconstruire
une nouvelle maison
mais je suis très angoissée par le futur
alors la reconstruire ici
c'est inquiétant parce que le terrain
est situé sur une faille tectonique et
qu'il risque d'y avoir d'autres
tremblements de terre
tout ça m'angoisse
chez nous on a de la chance car le
voisinage nous a beaucoup aidé
chaque jour nos voisins nous ont donné à
manger
et nous ont réconforté
ils nous ont écouté
grâce à eux on arrive à surmonter toutes
ces épreuves
il en a encore ici à la campagne
l'entraide fonctionne beaucoup
nous avons tous été victime et tout le
monde s'entraide
si on n'a pas de quoi manger on s'invite
les uns chez les autres
et toute cette gentillesse nous touche
énormément
et ça c'est plus important que l'argent
avant le toit de la grange était relié à
celui de la maison
mais maintenant la charpente est
complètement vrillée
ici on peut voir la faille dans le sol
21 avril le mauvais temps si redouté
arrive
et il va encore compliquer le travail
des sauveteurs
pire il est accompagné de répliques
provoquant la destruction dans la nuit
d'une partie du patrimoine culturel de
Kyushu elles ont sévèrement endommagé le
temple à Sceaux un sanctuaire shinto
c'est important monument japonais a
perdu sa tour portail ainsi que sa salle
de culte
l'eau de pluie s'infiltre par les
fissures et risque de favoriser les
glissements de terrain sur le sol meuble
effectivement
la falaise s'effondre à cause de la
pluie
les habitants des maisons au-dessous de
la falaise ont été ordonnés d'évacuer
[Musique]
si tout est réglé
il y a eu des secousses de haut en bas
pour le moment mais
il peut casser à tout moment donc nous
devons être prudents
oui des glissements peuvent encore
survenir donc soyez prudent
parmi les plus exposés les maisons
autour d'assaut ou le 17 avril la faille
en activité déplacea latéralement le
solde de deux mètres les fondations des
bâtiments sont désormais ancrés dans un
sol en particulier
le séisme transforma la terre en soupe
nous sommes impuissants devant les
forces de la nature
je me console en me disant que je ne
pouvais rien y faire
nous vivons seulement à deux dans cette
maison
nous pensons vivre avec d'autres gens
maintenant même dans des logements
temporaires pour un temps seulement
toutes les maisons ici ont été détruites
le second jour le premier jour la route
a commencé à se dégrader trois arbres et
un poteau électrique sont tombés sur ma
maison
[Musique]
mes jambes tremblent de peur
autour d'assaut les terres solides se
liquaient fier engloutissant route et
voiture et faisant même basculer les
bâtiments restés sur le sol meuble ce
processus de liquéfaction constitue à la
part la plus destructrice de la
catastrophe
les scientifiques se sont depuis
longtemps et forcés d'étudier ce
phénomène mais les chercheurs
s'accordent maintenant à dire que
beaucoup de leurs modèles présentent des
imperfections et échouent à donner une
représentation exacte des conditions
réellement existantes
bleus
la pression fait que le sol devient
liquide
affaissements du sol
les maisons se penchent comme celle
derrière nous
car le sol ne pouvait plus la supporter
le terrain ici à la particularité
géologique d'être recouverte de cendres
volcaniques qui se sont accumulés sur
les pans de la montagne
au beau milieu de la tourmente et de la
confusion une équipe de sismologues
japonais se met au travail pour établir
une modélisation 3D des zones touchées
ils essaient de comprendre les
structures tectoniques du lieu et les
forces en mouvement
regardez cette zone
ça s'est transformé en un escalier
le sol est très mou
je pense que lorsque des gros morceaux
de terrain ont glissé
sa surface ça a continué à
glisserait comme ça
[Musique]
nous prenons des photos de la zone
toutes les 5 secondes
nous utilisons ces photos prises sous
différents angles pour créer un modèle
3D de la zone
dans cette région plusieurs zones se
sont écroulées
nous regardons d'abord la photo
intégrale avant de décider où nous
voulons voir les coupes transversales
les mesures peuvent être faites à la
main
mais si nous avons besoin de section
différentes
nous devons les refaire
c'est pratique avec cette machine
car nous pouvons bouger et voir des
sections différentes
qu'elle va s'agrandir si les
tremblements de terre continue
[Musique]
le Japon vit en permanence sous la
menace de nouveaux séismes éruptions
volcaniques le pays entier est sous la
surveillance constante des sismologues
et des volcanologues
20% des séismes que subit notre planète
touche le Japon chaque année autour de
600 séismes par an
[Musique]
ainsi le 22 novembre 2016 un autre
violent tremblement de terre de
magnitude 7,1 fut ressenti au nord du
Japon près de Fukushima causant
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
au total la série de séismes à Kumamoto
et dans le reste du Japon a en 2016
causait la mort de 49 personnes et
occasionnées des dommages estimés à 7,5
milliards de dollars
quelques mois après que la plaque
tectonique Filippine a fait les gros
titres de la presse les mouvements d'une
autre plaque tectonique firent des
ravages en Italie
[Musique]
bassin méditerranéen et broyé par le
continent africain qui s'enfonce sous la
plaque eurasienne générant de complexes
failles de subduction
prise entre les deux la plaque
Adriatique tourne dans le sens inverse
des aiguilles d'une montre à la vitesse
de 3 mm par an autour de la ville
d'amatricice et des villages voisins de
la chaîne montagneuse des apnins au
centre de l'Italie
[Musique]
ces villages de montagne isolées sont
connus pour leur huile d'olive leur
truffe noire et leur vignoble
24 août 3h30 du matin un tremblement de
terre d'une magnitude 6,2 puissant bien
que peu profond frappa les villages
[Musique]
les villes d'Arquata prêt à del Tronto
furent parmi les plus violemment touchés
dans cette région
le prêtre local Francesco Armani est la
mémoire vivante de ces villages
la nuit du 24 août à 3h36 précisément
nous avons entendu un grand fracas et la
terre a tremblé de manière violente
j'étais au lit me réveiller
et on avait l'impression que la nature
voulait projeter mon lit au plafond
j'ai attendu la fin de la secousse je me
suis habillé rapidement et je suis sorti
les rues étaient pleines de gravats de
cailloux et de grosses pierres
et toute la population est sortie dans
la rue
je me suis levée j'ai enfilé mes
chaussons j'ai pris mon fils et avant
même la fin de la première secousse nous
étions déjà dans l'escalier
arrivé en bas nous sommes aperçus que
nous étions en pyjama à 3 heures du
matin j'ai dit non
à la seconde sous-couche on a entendu le
mauvais
un bruit effroyable
à cet instant tout s'est écoulé je me
suis dit ma mamie
nous étions justement sur le parking d'à
côté
et on entendait le fracas des pierres
depuis la crête du veto qui roulait
jusqu'en bas avec la secousse du
tremblement de terre
en 10 minutes tu regardes ce qu'il y a
autour de toi tu vois la désolation
la maison est sur pied mais si tu ne
peux pas y vivre c'est comme si tout
s'était arrêté
et voir ton village qui n'existe plus
c'est encore plus dur
le bus de l'école arrive ici j'ai
récupéré mon fils ici plein de fois je
le faisais goûter on allait chercher une
brioche emballée c'était la vie simple
essentiel mais c'était la vie je ne
l'aurais plus
excusez-moi
outre les pertes humaines une partie du
patrimoine culturel de l'Italie fut
également ravagé
une église s'est écroulée à pescarabe
elle a certainement Milan elle ne
s'était jamais écroulée pourtant des
tremblements de terre il y en a déjà eu
ce qui veut dire que celui-ci était
beaucoup plus violent
il ne s'agit pas des secousses
colossales que l'on observe à la lisière
des plaques tectoniques ou des séismes
de magnitude 8 et 9 peuvent se produire
dans cette région les failles sont
plutôt petites car peu profondes mais
quand le séisme se produit juste
au-dessus la secousse est spectaculaire
la réalité c'est que nous nous sommes
qu'un petit point sur la carte
géographique mieux nous sommes sur une
petite étoile
sur le site de l'institut de géophysique
italien on nous représente l'épicentre
avec une étoile
plus de 4000 personnes ont participé aux
opérations de recherche et de secours
238 personnes furent retirées vivantes
des décombres grâce à l'intervention des
autorités
[Musique]
les tremblements de terre sont à l'image
des balles d'une roulette russe on ne
peut jamais vraiment savoir quand et où
ils vont déchaîner leur pouvoir
destructeur
[Musique]
s
de vrais miraculés
que nous voyons derrière nous
il n'y a pas eu de mort il n'y a pas eu
de blessés
puis nous avons vu Pescara
alors nous avons remonté nos manches
nous nous sommes dit que nous sommes
encore là et que nous pouvions faire
quelque chose ce qui est arrivé à
Pescara c'est incroyable
[Musique]
et il fallait c'est pour 30 le village
malheureusement a été complètement
détruit d'ailleurs si vous y allez vous
ne verrez plus qu'un tas de ruines
il y a eu près de 50 morts
je les connaissais je les avais mariés
j'avais baptisé leurs enfants
je suis un peu sous le choc parce que
quand 20 30 40 ou 50 amis meurent
c'est forcément un drame intérieur et
une douleur profonde
c'est sûr nous aurons certainement des
difficultés à nous reprendre pour
repartir
[Musique]
j'ai vécu le tremblement de terre de
1972 et de 1997 celui de la Kila que
nous avons ressenti ici parce que nous
sommes relativement proches
mais pour moi ils n'ont pas eu cette
violence cette fois-ci par contre il
semble que le tremblement de terre a
suivi une ligne une ligne maudite comme
Pescara détruite
et à côté il y a un village Vezzano qui
n'est qu'à 500 mètres environ totalement
indemne
rien ne s'est écroulé
alors ce sont des phénomènes que moi du
moins je n'arrive pas à comprendre
la science peut-elle expliquer ses
étranges phénomènes
[Musique]
se séparent en deux et vous avez des
séismes successifs qui courent du sud au
nord l'un après l'autre à des semaines
et des mois d'intervalles créant des
failles des failles très connues des
failles que vous pouvez voir zébrant les
façades montagneuses dans ces régions
qui ont connu les plus forces séismes
depuis des centaines d'années ses
failles ont été brisées une par une
créant une brèche plus au nord
le long de l'axe principal des monsapna
en Italie
ce n'est ni la première ni la dernière
fois que l'Italie connaît un fort
tremblement de terre entre le 26 octobre
et le 3 novembre une dizaine de séismes
superficiels avec des magnitudes 4,5 à
6,5 on frappé en série la région de
matière rata ils se sont produits dans
une faille sismique entre la zone
touchée par le séisme du mois d'août et
lombrit une zone frappée en 1997
les failles se développent et le
processus de destruction se poursuit
[Musique]
298 personnes sont mortes dans le
tremblement de terre on estime après de
2,5 milliards d'euros le montant total
des dommages
[Musique]
des magistrats italiens ont ouvert une
enquête afin de vérifier si les
entreprises de construction avaient
passé outre les réglementations
antisismiques lors de la restauration de
bâtiments publics comme une école
amatrices réduite en miettes lors du
tremblement de terre
une controverse similaire est toujours
vive de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique où
les plaques tectoniques sont
responsables de l'une des pires
catastrophes de 2016
l'océan Pacifique le plus grand et le
plus profond des océans au monde cachent
sous sa surface un réseau de failles
conséquences de la tectonique des
plaques en particulier à l'ouest ou
l'immense plaque de Nasca s'enfonce sous
le continent sud-américain à la vitesse
de 60 mm par an
cette rencontre d'une plaque océanique
avec une plaque continentale crée des
frictions et qui dit friction de
l'écorce terrestre 10 volcans et séismes
en Équateur 60% des 16 millions
d'habitants vivent dans les régions
côtières et notamment dans la ville
principale goyaquil
le 16 avril vers 19h la terre gronda et
des pannes d'électricité affectèrent de
nombreuses villes
[Musique]
c'est au grand jour seulement que le
gouvernement réalisa l'amplitude et
l'étendue des dégâts causés par ce
tremblement
les villes de Porto vieiro Pedernales
Manta et Kanoa furent parmi les plus
touchés mais le fait que le tremblement
de terre se produise à la fin de la
journée juste avant que les habitants
aillent se coucher permis d'épargner de
nombreuses ventes
avec une magnitude 7,8 sur l'échelle de
Richter ce fut le tremblement de terre
le plus puissant de l'année 2016 et en
Équateur le séisme le plus important
depuis 1979
le président Raphaël Correa déclara
l'état d'urgence et dépêcha 13500
membres de l'armée des forces de police
et des pompiers
au moment où s'est déroulée la tragédie
les secouristes sont arrivés sur tous
les points critiques
pendant les deux premières heures les
pompiers se sont déplacés dans toute la
zone
et ont réussi à sauver des victimes
il y a eu beaucoup de survivants
puis il a fallu chercher les corps sans
vie
on dénombra plus de 600 décès dans les
provinces de manambie et Esmeraldas et
au total plus de 6000 blessés
le tremblement de terre s'est produit à
une heure qui grâce à Dieu a Épernay des
vies les gens travaillaient où ils
étaient dans la rue si cela s'était
passé une heure plus tardive ou très tôt
dans la matinée cela aurait été encore
plus compliqué et il y aurait eu encore
plus de pertes humaines
elle avait jeté sur des vagues de
quinte ça balancé de tous les côtés
vers le haut
j'ai aussi vu bouger une partie des
bâtiments de la ville
j'ai vu les maisons en face se lever ça
fait c'est et se relever
[Musique]
se trouve tout près du point de jonction
des plaques cette ville de 40 000
habitants fut particulièrement touchée
et beaucoup de ses édifices furent
complètement détruits
[Musique]
notre maison était composée de cinq
étages
quand les répliques se sont arrêtées
j'avais perdu 5 membres de ma famille
ma sœur de 17 ans est toujours sous le
choc
elle a vu le bâtiment s'effondrer en
entier et ma mère a vu l'effondrement
d'un bâtiment de 16 étages derrière moi
dont il ne reste plus rien
il a été entièrement détruit sur le coup
près de 30 000 personnes se retrouvèrent
sans abri l'eau le gaz et l'électricité
furent coupés dans de nombreux endroits
et des centaines de kilomètres de route
furent détruits beaucoup ont perdu leur
gagne pas
la douleur qui restera toujours c'est
celle-ci des années de travail des
cheveux en moins des cheveux blancs
tout est parti il ne reste plus rien 20
ans de ma vie
on a commencé par une petite propriété
un peu plus loin en bas puis on a changé
on est venu là à force d'efforts et de
sacrifices
on s'est endetté pendant 18 ans pour
rembourser la construction
mais avec la physique on ne peut pas
tricher
la structure Sévrier au niveau du
troisième
éducatrième étage
[Musique]
les gens étaient sous le choc tout le
monde était assis là à regarder moi
aussi j'étais choquée je ne pouvais pas
imaginer que quelque chose comme ça
pouvait arriver
mais depuis nous avons reçu de l'aide
nous avons commencé à recevoir l'aide de
la communauté
la coordination c'est ça le gros truc
d'essayer de coordonner les efforts de
tout le monde de façon à remettre son
pied cet endroit les gens commencent à
rebâtir leur maison et c'est formidable
on essaie de travailler avec les
autorités locales pour s'assurer que les
noms de construction sont bien en place
afin que quelque chose comme ça ne
puisse plus jamais se reproduire
l'équateur Maya et toute cette région
est une zone sismique extrêmement active
à travers l'histoire nous avons eu des
épisodes sismiques et ce n'est pas fini
cela n'est pas près de changer
l'ampleur et le mécanisme focal du
tremblement de terre d'avril sont
typiques de ceux d'une zone de
subduction entre deux plaques de grande
taille
un tel mécanisme produit les plus
puissants séismes que l'on puisse
connaître et quand la terre a tremblé
inévitablement de nouvelles secousses
vont se produire aux alentours ou bien
exactement au même endroit
nous voyons aux États-Unis ou en Europe
de grands Building et nous voulons nous
baser sur le même modèle
mais ici c'est différent nous devons
revenir à nos racines à nos valeurs
ancestrales le bois le roseau le bambou
pour vivre d'une manière durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement et pour
qu'il y ait moins de mort
l'une des choses à faire pour prévenir
le coup colossal en termes de perte
humaine tout particulièrement dans les
pays les moins développés et d'améliorer
les constructions
je pense que nos prévisions de séismes
ne fonctionnent pas le mieux que nous
puissions faire est de se dire oui on
s'attend à ce que des tremblements de
terre se produisent sur les lieux situés
à la jonction des plaques aux endroits
où nous constatons d'importantes Faya
actives et ceci doit nous conduire à
s'assurer que les villes les citées
proches de ces failles soient
construites de telle manière que
lorsqu'un séisme se produit nous n'en
savons pas la date mais lorsqu'ils
survient on est préparé les bâtiments ne
s'effondre pas sur les gens c'est le
moins que nous puissions faire pour les
populations tout particulièrement dans
les pays riches
les immeubles très récents ont subi des
dommages mineurs ceux qui n'ont pas
respecté les normes de résistance au
séisme ont été détruits
occasionnant des dommages de 3,3
milliards de dollars et causant la
majorité des 673 décès à déplorer
les mêmes problèmes de planification
dans les pays pauvres ont causé
d'énormes pertes de l'autre côté du
continent américain
les systèmes météorologiques de la
planète sont interconnectés d'une
manière que nous commençons tout juste à
comprendre
ils ont écrit le scénario du pire des
cataclysmes de l'année 2016
tout a commencé avec un phénomène de
mousson en Afrique de l'Ouest qui ne
présageait rien d'extraordinaire
alors la moussant africaine de cette
année était relativement active un peu
plus que la normale la mousson africaine
est annoncée par l'arrivée de ce que
l'on appelle les ondes tropicales qui
sont à l'origine de beaucoup de tempêtes
tropicales atlantiques
à ses débuts l'ouragan Matthew n'est que
l'une de ses ondes tropicales partie des
côtes d'Afrique de l'Ouest le 22
septembre
avec des conditions environnementales
favorisant un développement lent et une
activité orageuse croissante Londres
tropicale s'est déplacée vers l'ouest à
travers l'océan Atlantique
le 28 septembre Mathieu se transforma en
tempête tropicale à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres au sud-est de Sainte-Lucie
le 29 la tempête devint un ouragan à 310
km au nord-est de Curaçao
le jour suivant il augmenta son
intensité en catégorie 5 à la plus basse
latitude jamais relevée pour un ouragan
de cette intensité dans le bassin
Atlantique
a commencé à se déplacer vers le nord
assez lentement
l'ouragan va-t-il toucher terre mystère
Cuba et Haïti ressentir le souffle
humide du monstre et lancèrent l'alerte
rouge sur toutes les régions côtières
le 4 octobre à 7h du matin l'ouragan
Mathieu classé en ouragan de catégorie 4
frappa Haïti avec des vents de 230 km
heure
[Musique]
malgré l'anticipation les pertes
humaines et matériels sur l'île furent
catastrophiques
[Musique]
plus d'un millier de personnes
trouvèrent la mort lors du passage de
l'ouragan Mathieu et des centaines de
milliers de foyers furent détruits par
cette tempête
elle laissa plus d'un million de
personnes tributaires de l'aide
humanitaire et des dégâts estimés à
presque 2 milliards de dollars
[Musique]
après le saccage d'Haïti Cuba
le 4 octobre à 20h Matthew frappa de
plein fouetraoko avec des vents de 220
km heure
[Musique]
l'onde de tempête causa des dommages
considérables dans la province de
Guantanamo la splendide vieille ville
espagnole de Baracoa fut en particulier
terriblement abîmé
cependant grâce à l'efficacité de la
protection civile cubaine aucune perte
ne fut à déplorer
[Musique]
l'interaction avec la terre sur Cuba fit
faiblir l'ouragan en catégorie 3 bien
que Matthew ait finalement retrouvé une
intensité de catégorie 4 en quittant
Cuba pour les Bahamas
le 5 octobre Mathieu alors qualifié en
catégorie 4 frappa les côtes pour la
troisième fois
cette fois sur l'île de Green Bahama
les préparatifs commencèrent alors
véritablement dans le sud des États-Unis
à l'approche de Mathieu plusieurs
régions déclarèrent l'état d'urgence sur
les régions côtières et on ordonna des
évacuations massives
[Musique]
au cours des 36 heures suivantes la
tempête longea la côte sud-est des
États-Unis s'atténue en progressivement
tout en restant au large avant de
s'abattre une quatrième et dernière fois
sur les côtes de Caroline du Sud au
matin du 8 octobre le cyclone avait
alors la puissance d'un ouragan de
catégorie 1
les dégâts furent principalement limités
aux côtes de Floride et de Géorgie
aux États-Unis l'ouragan cause à la mort
de 47 personnes
[Musique]
le 9 octobre Matthew reprit la direction
du large et acheva sa transformation en
cyclone extra tropicale
[Musique]
et épargne les plus riches
parce qu'il frappe les plus pauvres
comme on Haïti ce fut un terrible
désastre en termes de pertes humaines
puis il est parti vers le nord si sa
trajectoire avait été d'une centaine de
kilomètres plus à l'ouest Matthieu
aurait provoqué d'énormes dégâts en
Floride mais quand enfin il atterrit aux
États-Unis il s'était affaibli ce ne fut
plus qu'une catastrophe en terme
d'inondation qu'en termes de vent donc
les États-Unis ont une chance inouïe
avec Matthew alors qu'Haïti manqua
cruellement de chance
avec des dégâts estimés à plus de 8
milliards de dollars Matthew fut
l'ouragan Atlantique le plus coûteux
depuis Sandy en 2012
mais tous les pays ne sont pas exposés
de la même manière
[Musique]
il y a de grosses différences entre les
premières puissances mondiales et les
pays en voie de développement
là où il est facile de souscrire des
polices d'assurance dans les pays les
plus riches les gens ont tendance à
construire des immeubles solides de
meilleurs bâtiments ils ont tendance à
suivre les règles les normes de
construction
et si vous travaillez dans des pays en
voie de développement ont tend vers plus
de risques les choses ne sont pas
construites aussi solidement et il y a
beaucoup de bâtiments dans les zones
inondables par exemple il existe moins
de protection pour les populations
et ce sont donc des défis très
différents à relever si vous établissez
des modèles de risque pour les pays
riches ou si vous réfléchissez au risque
pour les pays pauvres du tir monde où on
voit de développement dans lesquels les
conséquences des cataclysmes peuvent
être cruciales pour la vie des gens
l'année 2016 a eu sa part de catastrophe
[Musique]
incendie
seisme
[Musique]
tempête
sécheresse
[Musique]
inondation
mais peut-on savoir quel pourcentage de
ces événements doit être attribué au
réchauffement climatique
il existe aujourd'hui des techniques
permettant d'identifier la cause on
appelle ça des études d'attribution donc
ça se fait maintenant dans un certain
nombre d'universités quand vous étudiez
le TRIMA mondial depuis 1950 dans une
version de la terre où vous avez
l'augmentation des gaz à effet de serre
année après année et une autre version
de la terre où il n'y a pas eu ces
augmentations de gaz à effet de serre et
donc ensuite vous confrontez ces deux
versions de la Terre afin de découvrir
comment probablement une situation
extrême particulière ça peut être
d'extrême sécheresse ou d'extrême
précipitations comment cela se passe
probablement dans ces deux mondes et
cela vous indique à quel point les
changements climatiques et à quel point
le réchauffement global favorise
l'apparition de ces extrêmes
[Musique]
une certitude demeure les catastrophes
naturelles frappent plus les pauvres que
les riches
[Musique]
si nous pouvons au moins attribuer
quelques-uns de ces cataclysmes créés
par notre planète vivante au fait
qu'elle serait chauffe il reste
plusieurs jours que jamais d'instaurer
des politiques climatiques pour protéger
les plus vulnérables de ce monde
[Musique]